wow this is preparing to live stream the
meeting
setting up meeting
oh live streaming right
we are here uh
roger is here as well i believe everyone
can see both of us
uh we're gonna wait a minute or two for
people to get in here
um but roger thanks so much for doing
this obviously
um let's wait a second and see as people
come in
let's see all right we should be uh we
should get started here as people kind
of trickle in
um but maybe let's just start
with uh your background and kind of
where you grew up what you did uh before
you'd ever heard of
uh bitcoin or cryptocurrencies or
anything
yeah so i i was born and raised in
silicon valley uh it didn't
seem like any sort of a special place to
me uh because i was
i was born there um but i was around
computers my whole life i ran one of the
more popular uh bulletin board systems
uh in silicon valley for
those of us that are old enough to
remember what a bbs was for those that
aren't
enough to remember before the internet
people ran little local
bulletin board systems on their
computers where everybody in your local
town
would connect to and you could only have
one person connected at a time
per phone line that the bbs had and uh
but you had a lot more of a sense of
community on these bbs's than you have
on the internet now because with the
internet
anyone can be from anywhere whereas on
bbs as you knew that most of the people
were from your own little local town
uh anyhow i was kind of coming of age
right when the dot-com bubble was
bursting
and all these businesses were going
bankrupt and uh they were having
going out of business sales where you
could buy uh you know their their
computer parts for pennies on the dollar
and i wanted a hard drive for my own
computer
and i went to one of these auctions and
they were selling
nine gigabytes because the hard drives
for a hundred dollars each
and this is when ebay was just getting
started this is probably 1998 or so
and i saw these same hard drives that
were a hundred dollars each at the going
out of business sale were
almost 400 each on on ebay so i took all
the money that i had saved up which is
about
fourteen hundred dollars i'd earned
mostly from changing oil at a jiffy loop
type place
as a teenager and then bought all those
hard drives and then i resold them on
ebay and this is before paypal and i
remember
people literally had to go to the post
office get a post to money order
and then ship the postal money order in
the mail with a
stamp not email and you'd wait for the
postal money order to show up
and then you'd have to go to the bank
and deposit in the bank there were none
of
these
there was no iphone you couldn't just
take a picture of the check and deposit
it it was a giant headache and i started
selling these computer parts all over
the world because i figured out i could
make a lot more money doing that
than you know going to college and
getting a job at some you know big
company
uh and so been around computers my whole
life and
started a company called memory dealers
selling computer memory mainly
from these companies that were going out
of business or updating their systems
and we were selling this memory all over
the world
and a lot of people won't realize this
but before right now if anybody has a
stolen credit card one of the top things
people try and do with a stolen credit
card
is buy cryptocurrency but back then the
top thing that people were trying to do
with stolen credit cards would buy
computer memory
and so we were selling computer memory
and every single day we had people with
stolen credit cards
trying to trick us into selling our
computer memory to them with these
stolen credit cards so
i understood firsthand what a giant
headache it was dealing with online
payments
on the internet and payment fraud and
chargebacks and all this nonsense
and then you know years later when
bitcoin came along
i was like wow this solves every single
online payment problem
that people i remember when paypal first
came along too actually i was one of
paypal's biggest you know
uh you know affiliate marketers there
getting everybody to sign up for paypal
they were paying you you know five
dollars a person that would sign up and
i got hundreds if not thousands of
people to sign up for uh for paypal
there
and then for those that are older
remember eagle that was the same thing
when eagle came along i was a giant fan
of e-gold
and i sold my computer memory for e-gold
people paid me with e-gold for those
that don't know e-gold was this awesome
platform
that allowed you to buy and sell things
on the internet would pay in x number of
dollars worth of gold
and the gold physically stayed put in
you know different vaults but you would
just transfer the ownership of the gold
around online and that was really
starting to get traction and really
picking up steam
until the us government came in and
stole all the gold and i didn't you know
i was real young i didn't have a huge
amount of gold had a few thousand
dollars worth
um but that was gone and so because some
people on the platform use some of the
you know e-gold payment services
for some bad things the government stole
everybody's gold and then tossed the
founder of it in jail
and so that made me realize like as
wonderful as gold is his money
is if you're having to store it in
somebody else's vault and trust them
with it
you're kind of at their mercy and so i
lost all my gold and so did every other
gold customer and then maybe if you
jumped through a million
hoops and filled out a bunch of forms
for the lawyers maybe maybe a decade
later you might have gotten some of your
money back but i never uh
you know followed up on that just
because it was too much work it's a war
of attrition there
but uh been involved in tech and
payments uh
for you know decades i'm one of the
older people in the cryptocurrency space
so that's
a little bit about me although we left
out one of the more interesting uh
facts maybe in my life so uh i wasn't
born a libertarian but i
i started studying these economics books
as a young man and the more economics i
studied the more i realized wow
government intervening in the economy is
just retarding the world's rate of
economic growth and preventing the world
from being as prosperous and wealthy as
it otherwise would have been
and uh it became really really clear as
i studied this i thought wow if
everybody realized this
they would want the government to
intervene in the economy a whole lot
less so the world can be at a better
place so uh
maybe saying i made a mistake is a
little bit too strong of a word but uh
i took an interesting course in life and
i ran for california state assembly as a
libertarian
and my campaign platform was that i
would repeal as many laws as i possibly
could i would repeal as many taxes as i
possibly could
and even if i were to be elected i said
i wouldn't accept any salary whatsoever
because my potential salary would come
from taxpayers
and maybe those taxpayers wouldn't want
to pay my salary so i don't think that
it would be legitimate for the
government to force people
to pay my salary if they don't want to
so i said even if i was elected i
wouldn't accept a salary
and then in my campaign i got to debate
the republican and democratic candidates
and i called the atf and fbi
a bunch of jack-booted thugs and
murderers in reference to all these
children that they murdered in a church
in waco texas and
yeah the parents were you know religious
nuts but even if the parents are
religious nuts you don't burn to death
all their kids in a church and for those
that
aren't old enough to remember in like
1994 or something like that
there was this uh you know church group
in in waco texas
and the united states federal government
literally burnt to death i think it was
like
something like 30 kids were less than 12
years old that were in the building
and about 100 people total so uh
absolute uh you know black eye in
american history there
and anyhow the atf and fbi don't like it
when you call them jack-booted thugs and
murderers
so i wound up being the only person in
the entire country to be prosecuted
for selling these firecrackers on ebay i
was buying them initially from cabela's
sporting goods catalog and then
reselling them on ebay so
buying from one website selling on
another uh i didn't know i needed any
sort of permit or license the company i
was buying them from i asked them
specifically do i need a license to sell
they said no they're legal in all 50
states
uh for agricultural use only so i put
right there in the ads of you know these
for agriculture use only of course
everybody that knew that was buying them
new that like yeah
use them for agriculture but they also
work just like a firecracker and you
know people like firecrackers this is
back when ebay had a guns and ammo
section
anyhow really long story to a shorter
story
i wound up doing 10 months in federal
prison for selling these firecrackers on
ebay
and even while i was in prison the
company that was manufacturing
the company i was buying them from was
we're still selling the exact same
product
with no license while i was in prison
for doing the exact same thing so
it left a really really bad taste to my
mouth for uh
you know american law enforcement
because i've been brought up being told
oh
in america yeah freedom of speech you
can say whatever you want and you're
allowed to do that
it turns out maybe you have a little bit
more freedom of speech in america than
you know north korea or other
places but not that much and look what
they're doing to julian assange now or
edward snowden for telling the taxpayers
what the government was doing with their
tax money it's just a crazy crazy world
and uh anyhow the day i was allowed to
leave the country after my
10-month federal prison since uh i left
the united states haven't lived in the
united states ever since
renounced my u.s citizenship back in
2014 and uh
yeah that brings us i guess to where we
are today so so let's back up for a
second right
just so people have a understanding of
timeline um you grew up in silicon
valley
at what point uh did you actually run
what was the year that you ran for
a political seat yeah so the election
was november of
the year 2000. okay and then uh when
were you
um arrested or tried on the uh on the
federal charges
uh my i forget the exact date of when
everything started my prison sentence
started in 2002
and i got out in 2003 and it took some
time for everything to
you know wind through the gears of
injustice there got it okay
and then um in terms of that there's a
you know you get out of prison in 2003
uh obviously you've got this kind of
sour taste in your mouth
with the government law enforcement kind
of everything you just articulated uh
bitcoin doesn't come around until 2008
2009.
what are you doing in the five-year kind
of window between getting out of prison
and bitcoin never being released into
the world
yeah so um we should probably talk about
some of the books that i read during
that time that really influenced me so
like one of those books was a
kryptonomicron by neil stevenson
uh i'm sure lots of people are familiar
with neil stevenson one of the best
science fiction authors around and in
this book basically there are all these
people that are using this
it's been more than a decade since i
read the book almost two decades
probably um
but i think it was called cyber cash in
the book and basically it was this
peer-to-peer electronic cash that people
were using on the internet to buy and
sell things and
and mainly in the book they were using
to pay for secret data centers where
people could host their you know data
beyond the reach of governments to be
able to control or censor or shut down
these uh websites and that sort of thing
and it was really really interesting and
then another book uh was future
imperfect by david friedman in which it
talks all about public key cryptography
and how it works and
he's uh he's a physicist by training but
he's i guess a
teacher's law by profession um and so
the example he gave was once
anonymous peer-to-peer digital cash
comes around uh
he was gonna he was talking about how
people could practice law without a
license on the internet
and using digital signatures that you
could prove that you're dealing with the
same person over and over
and so he basically described something
like the silk road but for lawyers to
give legal advice rather than
drug dealers to sell drugs but it was
just so incredibly fascinating how all
this stuff is going to become possible
once and all the pieces of the puzzle
were in place except for the anonymous
peer-to-peer electronic cash and
and so i was you know basically just
kind of waiting in my life for the
peer-to-peer
anonymous digital cash to come into
existence and then when i heard about
bitcoin
boom there it was this thing i've been
waiting for but to answer your question
in the interim i've been focusing on my
business so memory dealers uh
grew up to you know have million
multiple millions of dollars in sales
every single year we employed you know
dozens of people around the world had
you know thousands of happy customers
all around the world everybody from uh
from nasa to the bureau of prisons uh
were our customers for our parts
um what were you selling what what is
memory dealers
so initially we were selling memory uh
computer memory and then later on we
actually
wound up focusing a lot more on fiber
optic transceivers and so we uh
worked with a number of contract
manufacturers and uh we started selling
agile star branded uh optical
transceivers and if you go
on ebay today you'll still see a whole
bunch of our used parts being sold all
over the world so it was really fun to
see
uh just that's one of the things i love
the most about business
is you get to meet people you get to
meet people all over the world and you
get to have friends all over the world
that you deal with
uh over and over so mainly we started
selling optical transceivers for like
the
the the rest of that time even though
the name of the company was still memory
dealers we still sold memory but the
main product were these optical
transceivers
uh and so i had enough capital and money
from that to when bitcoin came along
boom i knew this is going to change
everything so first step was to buy a
bunch of bitcoin
next step was to start investing and
bill helping build up all the businesses
that would enable bitcoin to be useful
for people in their actual lives to buy
and sell things
uh on the internet and uh everybody
loves to talk about you know i'm gonna
buy a lambo once with my sick crypto
games well
i had a lamborghini before bitcoin in
fact i had two before bitcoin had ever
even been invented ever
and the one that i had once bitcoin came
along i sold it so i could buy more
bitcoin so i went the reverse route in
that so
so the way that i wanted to kind of do
this conversation
um and for those listening uh roger and
i see
eye to eye on a lot of problems in the
world and
you know i think we both believe in a
digital currency future
we've got definite you know different
points of view or perspectives and some
aspects of how that gets implemented um
but what i really want to talk about
first is what are those problems in the
world
then the early days of bitcoin and kind
of rogers work there and kind of
a lot of the the insights and stories
and effort that many people may not be
aware of just because they weren't
around
um paying attention to that point and
then at the end of the conversation
we're gonna get into
bitcoin bitcoin cash um a little bit of
a technical conversation
and um kind of what the future looks
like so
um let's start with i think the things
that uh
99 we're drinking before like 99 of
people watching this
and listening to this are going to all
shake their head yes yes yes
uh which is the problems in the in the
legacy finance world and in kind of
the non-bitcoin or crypto world uh
just talk to me a little bit about like
what were those issues that you had
identified before you ever
saw bitcoin and then what are the things
that you knew
could be fixed with a digital currency
if it was implemented the correct way
yeah so one example of that that i think
probably just about everybody listen
this will
instinctually just feel isn't right is
is inflation right when the government
prints money
uh it's basically stealing from
everybody else that's using that money
at the same time and everybody kind of
feels and knows that but
it's actually even more insidious than
that i remember as a young man i was
reading a
milton friedman's book i think it was
free to choose
and in that book he talked about a
concept called bracket creep
and i i wasn't familiar with that at all
but it really made me think
oh that's why government is incentivized
even more so to inflate the currency so
everybody knows oh if the government
prints money they can then spend it on
you know their military stuff or you
know or maybe schools and hospitals and
roads and bridges like
they can spend on everything and
everybody is kind of aware of that but
it's much much sneakier than that so in
america and most countries in the world
uh there's an income tax and the income
tax is graduated the more money you earn
uh the the higher a rate you're gonna
pay in taxes so if you earn
a hundred thousand dollars you're gonna
pay a higher rate than somebody that's
running fifty thousand dollars and uh
it goes on and up up up and up and so
earning a hundred thousand dollars today
isn't anywhere near as much money as
earning a hundred thousand dollars back
in the 1980s was
so what the government is incentivized
to do with inflation is year after year
if you have you know your spinning power
is decreased by a couple percentage
points
before you know it earning a hundred
thousand dollars isn't that big amount
of money but if you go from running
fifty thousand dollars to a hundred
thousand dollars over you know ten years
um now suddenly you're in a much much
higher tax bracket
but you're not actually earning any more
money but you're having to pay a higher
percentage of what you're earning to the
government so governments are
incentivized
through inflation to bump people into
higher tax brackets so the government's
going to have a
higher percentage of people's money and
i i didn't even realize that that was
the case until i was reading about this
from milton friedman and so that's
something that i think a lot of people
when they hear about they think oh
that's a sneaky way to raise people's
taxes not just through the inflation you
know undermining their buying power
but using inflation to bump people into
higher tax bracket rates so that's a
really sneaky way
that governments all over the world are
able to to take more people's money
and uh and bitcoin can help put a stop
to that or any hard money
where there's a limited supply can help
put a stop to that if you have something
with a limited supply
governments can't inflate it anymore
they can't bump you into a higher tax
bracket without you actually having
uh be able to earn more money each year
and so
there's obviously the inflation problem
i think again every single person
listening to this will say yes that
makes a ton of sense
um there's this element of
censorship or surveillance maybe talk a
little bit about
how the traditional financial system has
issues that many people might not think
are a big deal because they feel like oh
if i'm not doing anything wrong
then uh you know why do i care but
obviously we've seen in other countries
whether it's uh
in a hong kong situation or elsewhere
where uh that centralized control
um and surveillance and and you know
issues that can stem from that so kind
of what are your thoughts there or
what had you thought of uh and paid
attention to before you saw bitcoin
yeah everything seems fine until it's
not
um and so i saw firsthand with a lot of
these
and e-gold was a great example of it
they literally stole all the customers
gold
because some of the people were using it
for payments that the government didn't
like so
uh everything in life is just fine
until it's not that's why you know it
pairs it pays to be prepared because
everything's fine i'm here in the
caribbean everything's fine but if a
major hurricane comes it's not going to
be fine so i need to prepare now and
have some extra food and water and
things available in case there is some
you know major major disaster
and the same is true you know in the
different monetary systems around the
world so uh
i was born in 1979 so within my lifetime
uh the us dollar uh was worth
at one point less than the zimbabwe
dollar right one zimbab
zimbabwe dollar used to equal more than
one us dollar
and now today you know it's a couple
trillion zimbabwe dollars probably for
one u.s dollar and that's an example of
how
things overnight can change or i'm sure
that you know the germans and the weimar
republic
weren't expecting their currency just go
to absolutely nothing you have to carry
around wheelbarrows of it uh
don't think it can't happen to you and
that's why it's so important to be
prepared to have something
that's there and uh is is safe and so
traditionally that's been hard money
like gold and silver
uh but more recently it's now gold
silver and cryptocurrency because
there's this other option
and all over the world people used to
use gold and silver as money
and then later they started using
banknotes uh for it and then governments
managed to successfully basically sever
the tie between gold and silver and the
banknotes now the banknotes you know
aren't tied to gold or silver anymore
but now we have this wonderful thing in
the form of cryptocurrency
and as long as we don't allow whatever
things
out there in the world to sever the
cryptocurrency asset itself
from whatever ious or whatever ways
people are using it
uh we won't have the same problem that
we had when the gold you know the dollar
went off the gold standard or when you
know
roosevelt literally told everybody
private citizens you're no longer
allowed to own gold turn in your gold
we're going to take it all like
if if everybody's using custodial
solutions for cryptocurrency stuff the
government can do the exact same thing
so it's important to have
cryptocurrencies available where people
can hold and use
and be in control of it themselves and
not just trust it with some you know
central custodian
uh like they used to do with gold and
then have the gold i used them before
you knew it
the dollar and the gold were separated
and so you talked earlier about
um kind of your experience with e-gold
uh and for those that didn't hear it it
was basically gold sitting in a vault
and then rather than
paper claims on the gold silver the gold
back dollar it was basically electronic
claims for over generalized description
and you could trade around those
electronic claims on that gold that sat
in a centralized vault
that system fell apart because they were
centralized control and the government
stepped in and ultimately confiscated
arrested people et cetera what was your
relationship if any with
kind of traditional gold it's not the
eagle but did you ever hold regular gold
buy gold interested in it at all yeah
um my parents actually my mother had a
purse in her
closet was filled with a whole bunch of
pre 19
i don't know 1967 like two silver
dollars and quarters or whatever the
year was that they stopped actually
being made of silver
and she had a whole bunch of those and i
thought that was really interesting as a
kid
but actually more recently when i first
got involved in bitcoin i
helped set up the silicon valley bitcoin
meetup and then the tokyo bitcoin meetup
and there was a real interesting guy
that showed up the tokyo bitcoin meetup
this is back in 2011
and uh i don't have one in front of me
but everybody's familiar with a penny
from the u.s right everyone knows what a
penny looks like
in japan there's a one yen coin that's
worth about a penny today
and it's it's it's made of it feels like
it's piece of plastic coated in aluminum
or something it feels even cheaper than
a penny if that's possible
and and for the most part you know they
have the you know leave one take one
type jars around like it's it's worth it
it's a penny so it's not much
but what this guy did he showed up to
the bitcoin meetup
and he had a u.s silver dollar from you
know 19 whatever
and he had a one yen japanese coin for
right before world war
ii and today a one yen coin is worth one
painting
it's really it's it's hard to overstate
how
chintzy a little tiny cheap piece of uh
i think it might actually be plastic
inside to be honest looks like it's
plastic coated in aluminum foil it's a
really
cheapy little thing but he brought a one
yen coin from right before world war ii
and back then a one yen coin
was one ounce of silver so he had a u.s
silver dollar
which was one ounce of silver and a one
yen
coin which was one ounce of silver and
right now the exchange rate for you know
dollars to you and one u.s dollar is
around 110 yen
and so a one ounce silver coin is around
twenty dollars
a one yen coin today right you're gonna
have to have what twenty thousand of
them
there to to be quite what it means is
that one dollar
used to equal one yen and for someone
who's been living in japan for a long
time the current exchange rate's over a
hundred to one
but it used to be one to one that was a
real eye opener for me so what it means
and the us government we know has
inflated the currency a huge amount
since world war ii just
huge amount the japanese government
inflated the currency
even more is what it meant and then he
also had
the one yen paper notes the paper bills
and he showed me this and he explained
to me that
you know during the war people that
saved the one yen silver coins
after the war they still had some assets
the people that saved the one yen paper
notes
had nothing after the war they had
absolutely nothing they were wiped out
and so that's why it's so important
to if you're trying to store wealth you
have to store it in an actual asset
not an iou representation of that asset
so uh
it was a fantastic example uh i think of
just how destructive
governments inflating the currency can
be and how destructive to
to the world's economy but to individual
lives of the people that are living in
the world and this is from somebody that
you know his family had lived
to that and he had these examples and
that's why he was so interested in in
bitcoin uh early on and i thought that
was a really powerful example
uh and and it had a big impact on me
so i want to start talking about bitcoin
now but before we do that uh everyone
who's watching on the live stream please
hit the like button that thumbs up so
that more people on youtube can watch
this and we can kind of share this
information
roger you were uh very early in
bitcoin and i think early in two
different things so one was timing
right in terms of uh my understanding is
about 2011
when you really kind of made a big move
into bitcoin but two
also early in conviction meaning that
you didn't just say oh this is an
interesting thing
let me put you know twenty dollars in
and see what happens
you made a pretty substantial shift in
in your
uh wealth and kind of your portfolio if
you will at the time
talk first about like when was the first
time that you came across bitcoin
did you read the white paper did
somebody tell you about it and what was
your reaction
yeah so like everybody the first time i
heard about it i didn't pay as much
attention as i would have liked to
so um i was listening to a libertarian
radio show called free talk live out of
new hampshire
and they mentioned it in reference to
the silk road and i was you know eating
breakfast at the time and i just kind of
you know
googled it real quickly and the price of
bitcoin that point there wasn't really a
price so the price was like
somewhere between one and ten cents and
there wasn't an actual
price it was just kind of a range like
whatever someone's willing to pay you
for it in that ballpark
is what the price was and i yeah i only
spent maybe five minutes looking i
thought oh this is kind of interesting
but too bad nobody's using it and
i didn't dig in deep and i didn't fully
understand how it's this decentralized
system and can't be shut down or
controlled and then
uh that was late in 2010 and then early
in 2011
i heard about it again and then i
googled it again and that's when i've
figured out i put all the pieces
together oh there's a limited supply oh
it's a distributed network
nobody can shut it down like this this
this is amazing
and that's when uh i literally got so
excited about bitcoin that uh
i i i i'm not exaggerating here i i'm
someone who needs my full
night of sleep every night but i was
planning to go to work that morning when
i
when i read about it i didn't go to work
i stayed home all day reading about it
i stayed up all night that night reading
about it into the next day until maybe 4
p.m the next day
and then went to sleep for only maybe
half an hour and woke up again and had
to read more about it
and stayed up all night again the next
night until maybe 10 a.m the next
morning and then
only went to sleep for you know maybe 45
minutes and that went on for about a
week of me only sleeping about you know
an hour a night
and then after about a week of hardly
sleeping at all
didn't leave my house once that entire
time only microwaved some food and
just focused on reading everything i
could find on the internet about bitcoin
uh i got really really really sick from
lack of sleep then i literally had to
call my friend and say
i lost my voice too even though i wasn't
talking to anybody i was only reading
i called and said help me i need you to
take me to the hospital and she was nice
enough to come and drive to my house and
and pick me up and drive me to the
hospital and they gave me some kind of
sedative and
i passed out for i don't know maybe 18
hours straight or something like that
and then i
woke up and it's been all bitcoin uh all
day every day for the last decade
and the guy that actually drove me to
the hospital that day uh he now owns uh
one of the the main bitcoin and bitcoin
cash and ethereum accepting restaurants
in silicon valley so if you like korean
bbq you can head on over to
korean spring barbecue right there in
santa clara it's fantastic food
and you can pay for it in cryptocurrency
as well and uh you can tell me you heard
the story about the time you drove me to
the hospital in
2011 because i was so excited about
bitcoin
that's a great story um and so when
you're sitting and reading
for that week and you're kind of diving
into all the information
what's your reaction like why are you so
excited about
the information that you're consuming
yeah so i've always been interested in
people having control over their own
lives
being able to do what they want with
their own money and their own career and
their own jobs their own buying and
selling of things
and we've had the internet for a long
time where people were able to share
information for the most part
unrestricted
and uh there's platforms where people
can buy and sell things
and advertise their things but the
payments that was always the missing
piece of the puzzle right if
if paypal closes your account you can't
use it anymore if bank of america closes
your account you can't use it anymore if
you get on the
you know olfact blacklist you can't do
anything anymore and now suddenly we had
censorship resistant money that people
could use to buy and sell things it's
like
i never bought or sold a single thing on
the silk road but philosophically it was
one of the most interesting things that
had ever happened in my entire lifetime
and i was
i spent a huge amount of time reading
their forms and looking at all over the
website and keeping
track of the different stuff that people
were starting to buy and sell
and that's what kicked off the entire
bitcoin and cryptocurrency ecosystem
where people buying and selling things
on the silk road using bitcoins for
payments and in fact
everybody today knows that bitcoins
aren't anonymous and aren't
uh are very easily traceable by law
enforcement but back then
everybody thought that bitcoin was
basically anonymous in fact like
most of the time it was even advertised
as anonymous i don't even think they
were really
particularly using the word uh
pseudoanonymous like
uh it wasn't until much later people
realized just how public
the transactions on the bitcoin
blockchain are
but back then everybody thought that it
was basically anonymous so people were
just you know
going wild buying and selling things on
these different dark net markets
it was just such an interesting
interesting thing to watch happen and
that's what kicked off bitcoin and gave
it its initial price and that's what
made it grow and grow and grow
and there's such an interesting uh and
so my my
fear at that point when people were only
using bitcoin to buy and sell
you know cocaine or marijuana or
different things on these things as well
governments don't like that governments
can demonize that so my goal
was to get people to use bitcoin in
commerce for things that aren't illegal
and so i had a long background in
e-commerce buying and selling things
so i set up this website called
bitcoinstore.com which was the very
first
mainstream websites selling products
that people would actually be interested
in because before i was selling fiber
optic transceivers
not too many people are interested we
advertise i put up a billboard in
silicon valley in 2011 saying
we accept bitcoin for you know fiber
optic transceivers get your you know x2s
and zinfax and sfp plus is from us but
nobody even knows what those are unless
you're really deep in that industry
uh but so what i did is i got i made
contracts with inger micro and tech data
which are the first and the third
largest
consumer electronics distributors in the
entire united states and i listed their
entire line cards for sale for bitcoin
and we only accepted bitcoin and this is
back when the price of bitcoin was like
you know 12 bucks each or something like
that
um and so now there are more than half a
million consumer electronic products
that you could buy for bitcoin
and we listed them all at our cost so
actually our prices for the most part on
most products probably
80 of the products our prices were
cheaper than amazon so that was a really
big deal so you could buy all these
things more than you know any computer
phone
any computer gadget you would want which
is what all crypto people are interested
in
you can buy them for bitcoin it price is
cheaper than amazon and so now suddenly
we were getting attention from fox news
and cnn and the wall street journal and
everybody because we were selling
millions of dollars worth of these parts
and you know i was on there on social
media you know tagging amazon and
tagging newegg and tagging tiger direct
saying hey
look at all this stuff we're selling for
bitcoin you guys are missing out on all
these sales you guys should be accepting
bitcoin too
and that's what really helped drive off
this uh worldwide adoption of bitcoin
being used in commerce and once bitcoin
was used in normal commerce where you
had the microsofts and the expedias and
the new eggs
accepting bitcoin it was then much much
harder for the politicians to demonize
bitcoin oh
that's a currency only for drug dealers
and money launderers you could say no
that's a currency for people to book
their next vacation on you know expedia
or that's a currency for people to buy
their new you know
uh home home computer system on new ag
right or tiger director all these things
so it made it much much much harder
for governments to demonize bitcoin or
try and shut it down so everyone loves
talking about censorship resistance of
bitcoin
i think one of the things that really
helps with the censorship resistance
is mass adoption the more people you
have using it the more difficult it is
to censor
and there's a great quote from mike
hearn another early bitcoiner he said
even outlaws can't use an outlaw
currency
and so if the currency is only used for
illegal things then you can't use it
anywhere you have
if you want to use a currency for
illegal things it has to be legal useful
for legal things as well just like the
u.s dollar you can use it to buy cocaine
you can use it to buy dog food uh and if
it wasn't usable for legal things nobody
would be able to use the us dollar to
buy illegal things either it has to be
for both
or it'll be for for neither so when you
kind of wrapped your head around this
and you're like wow this is really
impressive i think that there's a big
big future for this
uh i'm going to intentionally make a
move into bitcoin
was your first inclination to buy a
bunch of bitcoin
to set up the store you just described
where you would just accept it for parts
like
what were the what was like the first
thing that you actually did
once you kind of have made the decision
okay like this is the future and i want
to
go um and be a part of that yeah it was
all of those things in parallel but i
remember one kind of additional turning
point
uh i was talking on the phone to a
friend of mine telling him
and this i just made my first bitcoin
purchase and i was just getting ex
excite you know into all this and and it
was you know
a big purchase but uh i was telling him
all about bitcoin and he was not
convinced
and he told me very sarcastically at the
end of our you know maybe 45 minute long
long phone call where i'm telling him
all about bitcoin he says roger if you
really think bitcoin's so great why
don't you buy more of it
and you know he said it in a real snarky
way and when he said that to me on the
phone i told him
you're right and so i went out the next
day and i bought it even more bitcoin
uh so i should thank him for for doing
that but uh to answer your question it
was
all those things right buy some bitcoin
and then build all the software tools to
make it useful for people to use bitcoin
in their daily lives for absolutely
everything
and when we talk about buying a lot are
you
thinking of it in terms of a lot of
dollars a lot of your net worth like how
did you think about
um kind of the risk reward so you it
sounds like intellectually
uh convinced that um this is something
that solves an issue
uh that i've been paying attention to
i'm very intellectually curious about
this i'm intrigued by this type of
solution
uh i'm kind of convinced enough that it
has legs that i'm willing to put my own
capital at risk
but did you have kind of it as like an
investment idea was it like let me go
convert all of my fiat currency into
bitcoin you know on day one like just
how did you think
about um what risk you were willing to
take at that point
given that you know most people would
have argued like there was a very very
high chance i don't know 99 chance it
was gonna fail
right and it kind of wouldn't be it
wouldn't actually become what it has
become
yeah so i i put just about all of my
liquid net worth at that time
into bitcoin and bitcoin startups and
just plowed every every last bit of
everything uh into that
time energy and money uh that i could so
uh and one of the very first
in fact the first investment i made was
into a company called bit instant
which allowed anybody at any walgreens
or 711 or walmart to
walk in with a handful of cash and uh
within an hour or two they'd have a
bitcoins right there in their wallet and
so it made it really really
easy for people to buy their bitcoins
and then they could go and do what they
want and there was this you know
wave of uh you know merchant adoption
and people that were getting more and
more excited about using it for payments
because
anybody that had been involved in
e-commerce like payments are a problem
uh another
interesting example of that and i still
remember this to this very day it's been
this is pre bitcoin maybe this is 15
years ago but i got an email from a guy
and i to this day i feel sad for the guy
he emailed me and his email started out
he says
i am in nigeria and i know you don't
believe
me but i honestly want to buy some of
your optical transceivers
or computer memory i forget what parts
you wanted but uh
and because you know for better or worse
nigeria has such a horrible online
reputation like almost all the credit
card fraud and stuff is coming out of
nigeria so
what this guy did he sent me the email
and he said i'm going to pay you
everything in advance
buy wire transfer once you receive the
payment you can wait a couple more days
and make sure the wire doesn't get
reversed
and then you can send me the parts that
i'm ordering and i i and turned out his
order was totally legitimate we got the
wire everything was fine we sent him the
parts and i think he ordered a couple
more times after that
but i thought what an absolute headache
for that poor guy
being in nigeria anytime he wants to buy
anything from somebody he literally has
to send them an email saying
i'm in nigeria and i know you don't
believe me but here's what i want so
imagine if that guy
he's probably a giant bitcoin you know
cryptocurrency fan today because now he
can use it for all the payments
and he can contact these people outside
nigeria and say hey
i want to buy something from you i'm
going to pay you in advance from
cryptocurrency
my shipping address is in nigeria but
i'm paying you in advance with
cryptocurrency so you don't have
anything to worry about and people are
saying sure no problem it's not even an
issue
whereas back then even for a wire
transfer you're going to be skeptical
because they have these elaborate other
you know schemes that they do with you
know tricking people to send fake wire
transfers to the wrong person and
whatnot
so uh anyhow cryptocurrencies just solve
so many problems for online payments and
that's that's what
started the whole thing the silk road is
what got this entire ecosystem uh
started without any doubt and so many
people who are early
um you know one didn't have a capital
base like you had obviously
uh but two when they started to buy
bitcoin or acquire bitcoin through
earning or mining or whatever
their method was uh and let's say that
they started doing that five cents ten
cents a dollar five dollars
when all of a sudden it's hitting twenty
twenty five dollars if you were
getting bitcoin at you know five or ten
cents it looks like wow
my in us dollar terms you know i just
made an absolute
killing financially why not sell
why not kind of walk away in terms of um
seeing the us dollar value of how many
bitcoin you had going up
so much and so aggressively over the
coming you know two three four five
years
why not at some point just take the
profits and go do something else
uh because well and you could go do
something else but i can't think of
anything that's more interesting
uh that i could have an impact on than
cryptocurrencies and peer-to-peer
electronic cash for the worldline
ai is probably gonna be more interesting
but other than investing in ai startups
i'm not gonna have you know a much of a
direct impact there whereas
cryptocurrency
uh in peer-to-peer cash world i can have
a big not only can i have i have had a
big impact on that
adoption in the world and especially
back then i remember very clear when
bitcoin hit 30
for the first time in june of 2011.
the user experienced like it wasn't as
refined but the transactions were
literally basically instant not
basically free
they were free for just about all
transactions all the time if you hadn't
moved your bitcoins more than
uh you know within the last i forget how
many blocks the transaction was
completely free
and zero satoshis uh totally free so the
transactions were totally free
uh basically instant and uh and
irreversible that was amazing
and the supply was limited why would i
want to sell those for a bunch of
dollars that uh
you're guaranteed the us dollar is going
to go down in value over time you're not
guaranteed that cryptocurrency is going
to go up
but you are guaranteed the dollar is
going to go down and if at that point
for sure bitcoin looked like it had this
amazing amazing amazing future in front
of it because the user experience was so
incredibly good
there's no way you're going to get me to
sell any of those backed into dollars
that would be a
that would be ridiculous and and i know
i'm not a professional trader i've just
been a long-term value holder i look at
the things that are going to be the most
useful to the most number of people
around the world
i'm going to hold that for the long term
because the long-term price trend of
those things are going to be up
uh the things that aren't useful to
people well uh i maybe i'll sell those
so okay and and so um at some point
you go from what i'll consider just one
person who's
buying bitcoin investing in companies um
to
you end up getting the title of bitcoin
jesus right and
and that was i think a combination of
the work that you had done
in investing in companies um kind of the
the um
amount of time and energy you had spent
going and telling people about bitcoin
and trying to convince them that
this was the future tell us the story of
like what was the first time you ever
heard
uh that as a description for yourself or
a name for yourself
kind of what was your reaction when
somebody started to call you bitcoin
jesus
um yeah two questions are so the first
time i i i heard about it
or heard someone refer to me i think uh
was i was uh at like a there was another
startup that i invested in
cryptocurrency startup and there was
like a barbecue with like the founders
and some of the other investors and
it was this you know beautiful lake
house up in washington state
and a bunch of high school kids from the
neighboring house had come over and they
were you know maybe
15 20 high school kids or something i
was telling all these kids
about bitcoin and setting up wallets for
them and giving them all some some
bitcoin on their wallets
and they were all really excited because
you know young people digital currency
yeah this makes sense why would i
why would i use you know anything other
than you know online stuff
and so they were all really excited
about it and i was talking about you
know you can use bit instant to go out
and buy more
you know bitcoin at the 7 11 tomorrow
and all these kids are saying yeah i'm
going to go out and buy more this is
great like you know
these kids maybe were too young to open
a bank account or get a credit card so
this was finally a payment method they
can use and then one of the other adults
kind of walked up and you know i was
surrounded by all these kids and setting
them up on their
phones and sending them some uh bitcoin
one of the adults said roger it's like
you're
it's like you're a bitcoin jesus and you
have all your disciples around you
because all these kids were there you
know really excited about it too
and uh i guess somehow along the way it
just kind of
more and more people started calling me
that but i never called myself that i
didn't choose that name for myself
uh i'm an atheist and if you look at
what happened to the original jesus uh
he was murdered by the government of his
day so things didn't turn out too well
for the
original jesus i hope not to meet the
the same fate there
uh but uh it was basically impossible
from you know 2011 until
and still to this day for the most part
it's mostly impossible unless i'm
i'm in a real public setting that's not
crypt i want to be left on
uh but for sure up until probably 2015
or 16 it was impossible to meet me
and not hear about bitcoin and if you
would allow me i would set you up with a
wallet and send you some it was
impossible
to meet me uh through that point and it
wasn't until the fees on bitcoin started
to become a problem and the blocks
became full
uh that uh it was a little bit harder
for me to start
to continue giving bitcoin to anybody i
i met but that's that's
maybe that'll be part two of our
conversations yeah what was the thing
that drove you to do that right cause i
think that that is
it takes a certain type of personality
it takes a certain type of life
experience and a certain type of
person to not only say hey this is
something that i personally am
interested in want to do
but i'm actually going to go and every
person i meet i'm going to tell them
about it i'm going to give them a wallet
i'm going to send them some bitcoin like
what what drove you to do that or why do
you think you
had the inclination to do that versus
you know the hundreds or thousands of
other people who were into bitcoin at
the time but they weren't doing that
i think it was every single thing that i
was interested in life
is pushed forward by people adopting
bitcoin
or cryptocurrency now uh in actual you
know day-to-day life in commerce and so
those things if i had to you know name
off some of them it's like
i'm incredibly interested in the
singularity right when computers exceed
human intelligence
wow what an exciting exciting world
we're going to be in there
and so the best way to speak or one of
the ways to speed up the the
the advent of you know superhuman
intelligences
is uh through more economic growth right
the faster the economy grows the more
resources there are to devote this sort
of things
the faster we're going to get there so
uh and cryptocurrency helps enable that
because it
enables more economic freedom more
economic freedom leads to more economic
growth
more economic growth leads to you know a
a faster
advent of superhuman intelligences the
same thing with life extension
technologies right i don't want to die
if you die that's the most boring thing
that can possibly happen to you right
because if you're dead
you can't have interesting conversations
like this or do anything at all about
anything so
i want anybody who wants to be able to
to be able to live forever
the best way to do that is through more
economic growth so you can have more
research scientists and more
you know capital be devoted to figuring
out a way for people to be able to live
forever so you can enjoy
wonderful times with your friends and
family and people on the internet and
interesting conversations
for as long as you want to and at any
point if you decide you're bored of life
it's easy to end it if that's what you
want to do right so like that's another
thing that i want people to do to be
able to live forever if they want to so
superhuman intelligence you know uh
living forever
uh and then just more economic freedom
lifts everybody out of poverty you look
around the world like i'm
i'm having this absolutely amazing life
right i can go anywhere i want do
whatever i want you know eat whatever i
want live wherever i want
i'm fortunate i'm incredibly fortunate
to do that right
but there's other people that are having
really really hard times in life
right there's people i was lucky enough
to have been born in silicon valley what
if i had been born in some other part of
the world
right it would have been much more
difficult and other people think oh what
if you were born in some other part of
the u.s no i'm talking about what if you
were born in some
you know poverty strict in third world
country i would have had a
really really really hard time well the
best thing we can do
for these countries around the world or
these places around the world that are
poverty-stricken
is bring them more economic freedom if
you look at the different countries
around the world the ones with
the lowest standard of living are the
ones with the least amount of economic
freedom and because they have less
economic freedom they have less economic
growth so
it's so clear for those that are old
enough to remember you can look at east
and west germany right
in west germany they had a whole lot
more economic freedom uh
and and they were producing you know
porsches and mercedes and bmws and
people had a very high standard of
living
in east germany you had way less
economic freedom the government
controlled everything and about the only
thing they were able to produce
in east germany was a great big giant
wall to prevent people from to being
from being able to escape because things
were so horrible there
or today you know you can look at north
korea and south korea south korea is
wonderful they have a lot of economic
freedom there
compared to north korea where they have
hardly any economic freedom it's clear
which one of those two koreas you would
rather live in
and so anywhere around the world you
look at the places the places with the
most economic freedom
have the most economic growth and the
most economic growth leads to the
highest standard of living so if we want
to help people
all over the world it's by bringing more
the tools that enable more economic
freedom around the world and so like you
know the singapores and in the hong
kongs until recently have been fantastic
you know beacons around the world of
those sorts of things
so let's bring more economic freedom to
the world the places around the world
that don't have it
and i don't think the most effective way
to do that is to beg politicians oh can
you please you know
lower tariffs and lower taxes and lower
restrictions on businesses
i think the best way to do that is to
build the censorship resistant tools
that enable people to engage in commerce
to buy and sell whatever it is that they
want so long as it's peaceful with
anybody else anywhere in the world
and not need permission from the
bureaucrats not need permission from the
politicians
have the ability to either say no
directly or just have it be completely
hidden from the politicians and the
regulators and the bureaucrats
that you know maybe they raised some
chickens and they sold them to their
neighbor or they you know they made
something on the internet or designed a
website
and center received a payment for it
like let's build the tools that enable
people to engage in free trade around
the world
and not need permission from these
politicians around the world
that's how we make the world a better
place for everybody and if we can make
the world a better place for everybody
else out there
that makes the world a better place for
me too because this is the same world
that i'm living in so
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies that's the
best thing that i could possibly do
to make the lives of everybody in the
entire planet better and mine all at the
same time so i'm
as motivated as i possibly could be to
bring peer-to-peer electronic cash
that's censorship resistant where
anybody can buy and sell whatever they
want
for the entire world and that's why here
i am i've been in space almost 10 years
full-time
and i'm still excited about it every
single day i've been working on this for
almost a decade now
and i think i'm going to continue going
for another decade here as well
uh what could possibly be more exciting
about this so that that's my rant as to
why i'm so excited about this but uh
i hope the rest of you are listening to
this like this is the most exciting
technology that we have available
to make the world a better place for
everybody and it's here right now today
don't waste any more time right we're
all getting colder day by day
let's hurry up and bring this to the
world before we start talking about
um kind of bitcoin and bitcoin cash and
the differences there
uh my last question about the early days
of bitcoin is how would you describe the
bitcoin
community right it was obviously small
um there was
kind of loose coordination and um you
know some conferences and things like
that but like how would you
having seen from 2011 to maybe 2015-16
like
how did that evolve over time and how
would you talk about that that community
that was being built around this asset
yeah in the early days it was really
really really a wonderful wonderful
uh community i remember just being so
excited to just wake up every day and
say
and look online and see what new cool
things that people build for people to
be able to use bitcoin for and
you know uh metaphorically speaking it
just felt like everybody was holding
hands and seeing kumbaya all day every
day about bitcoin because
all of us were on you know this this
team of bring peer-to-peer electronic
cash for the world that was going to
enable more economic freedom for the
world and
tear down you know government barriers
to people uh engaging in trade and
making the world a better place like
that's the thing that i think a lot of
people in cryptocurrency will
already appreciate but a lot of people
don't understand anytime anybody buys or
sells
anything with anybody uh both people are
better off after the trade when you buy
a new tv
it's because the person that sold you
the tv values the money you gave them
more than they value the tv
it's because you value the tv more than
the money you gave them so after the
trade
both people have something that they
value more than before the trade
otherwise the trade wouldn't have taken
place so the more trade we can enable in
the world
the better off everybody's going to be
so we need to build the tools
cryptocurrency and cryptocurrency tools
to enable people to be able to trade
with each other because that's how you
make everybody better
off all over the world and i bought some
you know fantastic little nuts earlier
today
i value the nuts more than i value the
money i paid for them the person that
sold me the nuts values the money more
than the nuts
both of us are now wealthier after i you
know bought these nuts from them
so we need to build the tools where
people can do this without needing
permission from
from anybody anywhere and uh
and that's been the goal for me and that
was absolutely without any doubt the
goal of the early bitcoin community was
building the tools
for people to be able to buy and sell
anything uh with anyone
anywhere in the world and not need
permission and uh the you know the
payments were supposed to be fast cheap
and reliable and that's what it was uh
all the way up until maybe 2015 issue
that really started to change
all right so we're going to have a
conversation about bitcoin and bitcoin
cash
uh i want to kind of put a couple
caveats for those that are listening
uh roger and i again 99.9
of what we just talked about uh we agree
on in terms of the problems in the
pollution it's not just a kind of a
inflation type thing there's multiple
impact that can happen from this being
coming globally adopted
what i don't want to have is people to
think that roger and i
are here to argue over all kinds of
different things uh
i think that roger and i have uh
a view of the world where the question
is
how do we get there right it's kind of
like we we agree on all the problems
and i think we agree actually on like
the finish line if you will or
or the goal that everyone is working
towards the difference of opinion
is uh what is the path to pursue and
um i think roger would agree with this
and i'll give you a chance here to
agree or disagree in a second but i'm of
the belief that like
experimentation and innovation and all
of these things should be encouraged
even when
you disagree with the way that
somebody's going to do something right
and
there's plenty of people who may not
like that but but i generally think that
there's ideas that come from those you
agree with and those that you don't
agree with
and so understanding both the way that
you think and also the way that other
people think is really important so
that's kind of the goal here
is to talk through it now with that said
uh
as we can see in the live chat uh
through twitter previously
there's tons of people who have tons of
opinions here and so we're gonna try to
do our best to
navigate this uh in kind of the most um
intelligent way and stay out of what
i'll call
all of the troll type content although
yes you guys make us all laugh
uh roger and i were joking about it
before we started um you know
the memes the jokes like we get it uh
but we are going to try to kind of keep
this as high value of a conversation as
possible
so with that all said um roger
talk to us about you go from 2011 to
you know 15 16 into 17 uh and you are
one of if not the most recognized
supporters of bitcoin and at some point
you start to change your mind in terms
of is bitcoin the solution
that can solve these problems um when
did that
start and kind of where did you start to
diverge in terms of
wait a second this may not be going the
way that i think it should go or this
may not be the actual solution that
we need yeah there were a couple of
steps in that process but i remember one
of the
the bigger epiphanies i guess
in in that process there was a i was
hosting a bitcoin meet up in silicon
valley was at the korean barbecue
restaurant there again
and you know probably about a hundred
people showed up that night there were a
bunch of people there
and that you everybody was paying this
is before bitcoin cash or i think this
might have
been before ethereum existed uh as well
um this is you know pretty early days
everybody was there was excited they
were paying with their
their blockchain.info wallet i think was
the main mobile wallet back then that
everybody was using anyhow they're
paying for their meal in bitcoin
the owner of the store was super happy
to be accepting bitcoin for all the
payments
it was a really fun time so like 100
people showed up there and of the 100
people that were there
97 uh were in favor of hey yeah this is
great i'm going to pay for my meal on
bitcoin bitcoin is gonna be money for
the world
everyone pretty soon is gonna be using
bitcoin to buy and sell and pay for
everything with everybody
but there were three uh bitcoin core
developers that showed up there
uh that evening uh and it was luke jr
uh eric lombroso and uh brian bishop
were their names
and they literally spent the entire
evening there arguing with the other
97 people there were only three of them
that had that opinion that evening and
there were about 100 people there they
spent the entire evening telling people
that they should not be using bitcoin to
pay for their dinner
they should be using credit cards and
they spent the entire evening they're
arguing with people that bitcoin is not
good for payments and people shouldn't
be using bitcoin to pay for things
people should be using credit cards i
remember uh another early bitcoin uh
guy i who loves his privacy so i won't
tell his name but he'll know who he is
when he hears this
um he asked him i was like what if i'm
someone living in in venezuela
and i need to pay somebody or i need to
pay for something in venezuela and
there's you know sanctions so i can't do
a uh you know whatever and he's like
well you should use a credit card and
they said well what if my credit card's
blocked and then you know i think it was
luke jr one of these those three guys
said like well
you should have a backup credit card and
it just seems so bizarre to me that
these guys came to a bitcoin meetup and
spent the entire evening arguing with
people they shouldn't have
used bitcoin to pay for their meal and
they shouldn't be using bitcoin for
payments they should be using credit
cards instead
and that was kind of where like i
thought wow there's a a new group of
people
in bitcoin that don't think bitcoin
should be used as money and aren't
interested in bitcoin being usable to
buy or sell things and they want people
to use credit cards
instead so hold on a second i want to go
slow here just so we can kind of really
get into the details uh i wasn't there
right obviously
you're recounting an experience that um
i i wasn't there for and
why do you think that was their opinion
or why were they talking about that
and obviously you're not them right so
there's gonna be some speculation but
what do you think was driving that
um conversation or that point of view
yeah so there's there's a great clip i
think that's on youtube people can
search like
roger ver luke jr bitcoin opinions or
something like that
and so you know there's this girl in
japan uh who asked me
why are you interested in bitcoin or and
i said because this is like
one of the most amazing technologies
ever like we summed up you know
in the first you know half hour of our
chat here and then she asked luke jr the
exact same question why are you
interested in bitcoin
and this is what luke jr is one of the
guys that was there telling people you
should use credit cards not bitcoin
uh and he's pauses for ein it's a really
long awkward pause maybe you know
20 full seconds and it's a long pause
and then finally the answer it comes up
with is that
it's interesting technology and like
yeah okay bitcoins and blockchains it's
interesting technology but the reason
it's interesting technology is because
it enables more economic
freedom for the entire world which
enables more economic growth which
enables
all the wonderful things that people
want to have in the world and luke
just thinks it's interesting technology
and luke was somebody who literally
believed in bitcoin so little that he i
need to hardly held on to any at all he
had to have a fundraiser recently
to pay for a dsl line for his house
whereas anybody you know
i believed in it so much i put you know
almost every you know almost all of my
liquid net worth i put right into
bitcoin
and i think that that's another kind of
interesting
thing out there is that so many of the
people that
before bitcoin had split were in favor
of not using bitcoin for payments and
just using credit cards for everything
they hardly held any bitcoin at all
there was a really interesting voting
website where people could sign
with their bitcoins at an address and
vote on different topics and like
it was like 97 or 98 of
of the bitcoins that vote it was this
huge amount of bitcoins hundreds of
thousands of bitcoins it was lots of
bitcoins
hundreds of thousands of bitcoins had
voted and they were almost all in favor
of
you know bitcoin being able to scale on
chain uh
for to become money for the world and
yet that's not what wound up happening
eventually
so okay okay so we have the kind of the
the first
you know incident i guess where um you
hear people talking about
not using bitcoin as cash and kind of
having a different
perspective where how do we get from
that
to eventually um having a fork and
um the more detail and kind of you know
timeline based you can go so people
understand because
there's frankly whether people remember
this or not there wasn't that many
people
that are in bitcoin and cryptocurrency
today uh they weren't around that so
they
kind of didn't get to live through this
like you did um
and so maybe walk us through um you know
you leave that dinner what are the next
events that transpire that kind of
continue to push you further and further
into
uh wait a second this may not be the
solution that uh that you wanted
yeah so there was another kind of
turning point as well that i remember so
uh
there's this thing that bitcoin has that
bitcoin cash doesn't have it's called
replace by fee or rbf for short
and bitcoin that's that's new to bitcoin
i think i think that was probably
implemented in 2015 or so
so and what that does is it made it all
the time in the early days that once i
sent you bitcoin
that's the end of the transaction
there's no way for me to get that
bitcoin back once i broadcasted the
network the network rule was called
first scene first safe which meant the
net the transaction that the network
sees first
that's the one that's going in the block
and even if it sees a different
transaction later with a much higher fee
ignores that one because it didn't see
it first and so peter todd and a number
of other you know core developers
really pushed to have this thing called
replaced by fee implemented which made
it so that if i send you some bitcoin
and let's say i pay you know a one cent
fee i can then
any point up until when the transaction
is uh including the next block
i can then instead of that bitcoin going
to you i can send it back to me or send
it to some other person or do whatever
with it
and pay a two cent fee or a two dollar
fee or whatever fee that's more than the
amount that i send a tour
initially with which makes bitcoin much
much much
less useful for people to buy and sell
things in
much less commerce hold on before we get
into kind of the different bitcoin and
bitcoin cash
come back to um as you are kind of
becoming convinced that
hey there there might have to be
something else were there other moments
that you remember
that kind of drove you to to think that
or was this kind of you have that one
initial dinner and then
you know over time you just slowly
become convinced that there needs to be
another solution
no th this is one of the moments so
because there when this rb rbf was
happening there was no bitcoin cash
there
ethereum wasn't i don't know if it even
even launched yet or not right
and so there's a big argument within the
bitcoin community though people are
arguing like
hey please don't do this this makes you
know bitcoin
less useful for commerce so eric
voorhees wrote a fantastic essay
like an open letter to peter todd asking
him you know
i know you're a really smart guy you're
a good you know cryptographer and
you know brilliant mind i think is what
the the word that eric used
he said but this please understand that
this severely damages the use case so
eric had started a website
or bought a website called satoshi dice
in like 2012
it got integrated into the
blockchain.net info wallet and that if
you can look on the the blockchain
history
that's when bitcoin transactions really
went through the roof because everybody
was busy playing satoshi dice because
you would send in your 100 bucks if you
won you would get back 200 bucks
instantly worth of bitcoin
and it was just boom boom boom boom boom
on chain instantly just like that it was
a really magical experience where people
all over the world were busy playing
this
and rbf not only ruined that but it
ruined you know businesses like
uh bitpay trying to accept payments and
all sorts of businesses all over the
world it made it much more difficult to
accept bitcoin for payment so
myself and eric and a whole bunch of
other people were saying hey
we need to be really really careful
about doing anything that makes bitcoin
less useful in commerce because the
entire goal at that point for
at least myself and a big majority of
the bitcoin community was get
as many people using bitcoin in commerce
as quickly as we possibly could
so the regulators wouldn't have time to
realize oh wait the dollar might lose
its you know
world reserve currency status everybody
might start using you know free market
money rather than our
you know uh you know pieces of paper
that we can print as many as we want at
for any time
and so by integrating that lots of
people were upset within the bitcoin
community but there was still just one
bitcoin
and things were still moving ahead and
then
the other big turning point to answer
your question there that really made me
worry about the future of bitcoin was
the fees were getting higher and higher
like
you know at first the fees were zero and
then the fee started being a penny and
then two pennies and then you know a
nickel
and then a dime and then you know 20
cents and they were creeping higher and
higher
and there was some sort of an interview
or or some online
comment somewhere and i forget exactly
where it was but
it really made me think oh my god this
is a big problem and i think it was adam
back
when i realized that he wanted the fees
to be high
and they were excited for the fees to be
high and that's when i realized
oh my god if they intentionally make the
fees on bitcoin high
nobody's going to use it because anybody
that studies economics
when you'll know that when something
costs more people use less of it if
you're if your electricity costs more
per kilowatt hour
you're going to use less electricity
than if it costs less if bitcoin
transactions are more expensive to make
people are going to make fewer bitcoin
transactions and that was the real
big turning point when you say that
you thought that they wanted to make the
fees high why exactly did you think that
uh they started openly saying it uh
there's
maybe this is news to you maybe you
didn't realize it but you can actually
see quotes from
people like adam back the founder of
block stream where he says he can't wait
for
for you know the fees to get up to a
hundred dollars per bitcoin transaction
or you know maybe even get up to
hopefully they can even get up to a
thousand dollars someday and then
greg maxwell one of the founders of
block stream and the cto there there's a
email from the mailing list there where
he's talking about you know hooray
pop the champagne the bitcoin fees are
over fifty dollars a transaction this is
you know
this is a great fit step for bitcoin i'm
summarizing a little bit but he
literally said you know pop the
champagne this is such a
big success for bitcoin and for people
like myself that have been accepting
payments
from people all over the world in
bitcoin and then
more times than i can count i had to pay
more you know thousands of dollars in
fees for a single bitcoin transaction
then you'll see
all some of these people that you know
disagree with me they say oh roger's
lying about that i'm not lying you can
see the transactions there's like
hundreds of thousands of transactions in
which people paid
more than fifty dollars i i didn't have
the data in front of but i i think it
may even been i think they're like
more than 30 000 transactions in which
people had to pay more than a thousand
dollars
in fees to send a single bitcoin
transaction and i remember one of the
convoluted roger so let's back up for a
second
um again i don't know what quotes those
are right so
so i can't kind of um agree or disagree
on it so we'll just leave that as it is
let's maybe for people to understand
when you're talking about
fees and transactions and all this stuff
walk
people through the design of bitcoin
and where you think that the design is
flawed right so i think this is one of
the key pieces that eventually led to
bitcoin cash and some technical changes
that happened but in terms of how
bitcoin works
when you're talking about the high fees
where did the high fees come from
so the high fees came from having an
artificially imposed limit on the amount
of block space that the miners are
allowed to produce
on the bitcoin blockchain so the blocks
on bitcoin
are limited to about one megabyte
there's a little bit extra because of
segwit so
in the ballpark of one megabyte 1.2
megabytes
and so inside that one megabyte you can
fit about 2
500 transactions every 10 minutes if
more than 2
500 people want to make a transaction
every 10 minutes on bitcoin
only the 2 500 people that pay the most
money in fees will be the transactions
that are included in the block
so everybody has to bid against
everybody else so if you're
if there's 5 000 people that want to
make a transaction only the top 2
500 that paid the most will be included
in the next block and then the other 2
500 hat will have to wait until a future
block and and there's this thing called
the mimpool which is basically the queue
of transactions that are waiting to be
included in the next block
and only the top 2 500 transactions
approximately
are included in each block so at the end
of 2017 when everybody was trying to use
bitcoin and people were trying to move
it in and out of the exchanges and
things were really busy on the bitcoin
network
the average fee for the transaction got
to be over
50 dollars for a single transaction and
the average confirmation time to be
included in a block
wound up being more than two weeks right
so that's
absolute disaster for anybody that's
trying to use bitcoin for payments fifty
dollars
on average per transaction and more than
two weeks on average for a confirmation
time
and remember in that two week period you
could potentially reverse the payment
using this
replaced by fee stuff that had been
added into bitcoin as well
it was an absolute master so
you just described bitcoin's design at
some point
you and a bunch of other people decide
hey we can
create a technical version that is
similar
but different that we think has
advantages to it
walk us through um what
forget how it's designed for a second
how did that come about
right is that you make a phone call to
somebody
and then all of a sudden you know people
start calling each other and say hey
this is a good idea
does somebody call you like just walk me
through kind of operationally
how does the idea come together to fork
bitcoin and create something else
it's actually the reverse of that so the
plan from bitcoin
from its inception all the way up until
later
was that the blocks would just get as
big as they needed to be in order to
accommodate their transactions so it was
people like
the bitcoin core developers and the
block stream guys and those guys
they're the ones who got together and
said hey i have an idea on how we can
make bitcoin better than what it was
originally
and the ideas they came up with to make
it better was this replace by fee thing
that i
told you about and by limiting the block
size they thought that by limiting the
amount of
transactions that the bitcoin network
could could handle that would make
bitcoin better
and people like myself and everybody
else disagreed and we wanted to go on
the original path
for bitcoin which was to allow as many
transactions on chain as possible okay
so part of this and i think why i wanted
to do this is
i think you and i both have the ability
to state our opinion and then also flip
around the table and say hey the people
who disagree with me believe
x because of y right the people who
wanted to limit the block size what is
their argument as to
why that is a good thing to do right so
understand that you disagree with it but
what is it their argument in terms of
why they believe that to be a good thing
sure so their argument as to why they
think that's a good thing is because if
you allow the blocks to get bigger and
bigger
it will require a more expensive
computer to run a full node where you
have the entire blockchain there
and if you keep the blocks small you'll
be able to run a full node on a much
smaller cheaper computer
potentially on a home internet
connection or even a raspberry pi
and so in their view of the world that's
a really really good thing because more
people all around the world will be able
to run full nodes and if you have more
full nodes around the world
it'll be harder for governments to shut
down all of those full nodes
i agree with that but i think that they
didn't if i can give the other side of
the
the point of view there the other side
of that is if you get everybody around
the world using bitcoin for commerce
you'll have you know companies like
walmart and amazon and tiger direct and
everybody else that's using it
you'll have all sorts of businesses that
have an economic need to run a full node
and i don't and even today almost
nobody's running a full node there's you
know maybe a couple of tens of thousands
of full nodes in the world
if that on the bitcoin network and
there's tens of millions of users so
it's a very small percent are using them
and so my point of view is if you want
to give bitcoin more censorship
resistance
you need to get as many people around
the world using bitcoin
in commerce in their daily lives as
possible whereas the other side of the
the view here is that we need as many
people on the network
running full nodes as possible but we
don't care about what the total number
of people
using the network as a whole is okay uh
those are the kind of the two world
views on each side
for uh the purpose of this conversation
i'm gonna generalize those two arguments
as security and convenience right and
and i know that those aren't necessarily
dead-on descriptions but basically one
is
the decentralization of the network
based on the full nodes ends up being
a related argument that says hey
decentralization is really really
important
the other argument is that you can have
the convenience
so fast if i can have a little bit i
think the other side of the argument is
that actually by having more people use
it in commerce
that adds additional security so i think
that they're both security arguments
the small block is a security argument
but the big block side is also a
security argument that you get more
security by more adoption
okay so so fair in terms of uh you're
getting security from two different
areas right one is more of
a deterrent and one is the computer
science type security so
now let's talk um in terms of uh
when the small block big block debate
goes on
obviously very very contentious uh
literally to the point where
um you know i call it the the
multi-faceted intellectual war played
out there was everything from the memes
on the internet to like
some very ugly debates both publicly and
privately
um and ultimately it came down to the
market trying to decide what to do
right and so maybe describe kind of how
the market how that process works and
then ultimately
um the the beginning of bitcoin cash and
kind of
how that uh played out or became uh
into reality yeah so the the online
discussion about bitcoin scaling
you know started brewing maybe it
started to heat up in 2015 i would say
and then
by 2016 and 2017 it was starting to
really get
heated and for the most part i was just
watching and so like
in my heart and with my economics
background like i know when you have a
production quota
which is what i view the block size
limit is it's just not externally
imposed production quota that leads to
inefficient outcomes
uh there so but uh i was for the most
part keeping quiet and just watching
because i thought maybe there's some
really you know good
other argument as to why the block
should be kept small
and i wanted to see and understand that
and then evaluate both sides and then
and then decide so i was pretty much
silent in regards to the debate and then
what actually made me decide to start
speaking up
was when i watched the the small block
side of the debate
openly start to censor and delete the
posts and try and silence
the people that were on the big block
side of the debate and when i saw their
two camps one side is supporting free
and open discussion
the other side is doing everything they
can to silence the other side's opinions
from being heard
well that was everything i needed to
know about which side has a stronger
argument
and that's when i decided to start
speaking up myself okay
so um i've heard you say this before
explain
where you saw that happening um and
again there's a lot of people who are
listening to this who just they weren't
around then right so they don't know
kind of how the debate was playing out
uh i can say it's all i'm blue in the
face that like it was
heated and controversial and played out
in every nook and cranny on the internet
behind closed doors like it was a real
deal but kind of what were the things
that you were seeing
that led you to say hey wait there's uh
your belief was that there was
censorship going on
yeah so there so now there's a lot of
different platforms you have crypto
twitter and there's a bunch of different
subreddits and there's more stuff
in the ecosystem now than there used to
be but back then
there was our bitcoin on reddit and that
had more traffic
for people learning about bitcoin and
cryptocurrency than probably
every single other website in the world
combined that's how big of a deal
our bitcoin was and then the second
place thing was this other website
called bitcointalk.org
uh and so both of those uh definitely
had more [ __ ] people new people coming
to crypto and learning about it
than every single other website even
every coin desk and coin telegraph and
you know
there wasn't any bitcoin.com i don't
think quite yet at this point
um uh there was there was more of that
uh you know
people learning on those websites than
everywhere else combined and then all of
a sudden what happened overnight the
main moderator of our bitcoin was this
guy named thamos that we don't really
we're not really sure what his real name
is
there were a bunch of moderators that
people knew so there was like a you know
one example this is jason king
who had been running like a homeless
outreach thing called sean's outpost
down in florida
and people were donating bitcoins to him
and he was using the bitcoins to buy
food and you know clothes and helping
homeless people in florida it was
fantastic he was one of the moderators
and he's an early early bitcoiner
since maybe you know 2011 or something
as well and everybody knew and liked him
and everybody knew and
liked the other moderators there and
there was a people disagreed but that's
part of the fun part about internet
forums people can type back and forth
and state their opinions and then all of
a sudden overnight
they most removed all the moderators
that people knew and liked and respected
and put in a bunch of new moderators
that nobody knew who they were they were
all using fake names nobody knows who
these before
and then anybody that even tried to post
any sort of opinion in favor of bitcoin
being able to scale on chain
they would have their post deleted and
their account banned from being able to
post there
and they did the same thing on
bitcointalk.org so you had the two
biggest websites that had more people
learning about bitcoin and discussing
this and every other website combined
suddenly silencing anybody from being
able to state an opinion that wasn't in
lockstep
with uh this guy famous in the small
block position which was clearly at that
time the minority position and then
right after the censorship started there
or the new you know moderation policy or
whatever they tried to disguise uh
disguise it as the one of the posts
there was like hey
we need to bring back free speech and we
need to allow the discussion it was the
most uploaded post ever and they they
called for famous to step down as the
moderator
it had more upvotes i think than any
other post ever to this very day
on our bitcoin and everybody was saying
yeah we want free speech and then what
did they do
they deleted that post as well and
censored that one as well so it was just
a really just shocking thing for me
where
bitcoin was supposed to be censorship
resistant money for the world and now
suddenly the bitcoin community is
engaging in massive censorship within
about even talking about
bitcoin it was it was absolutely
heartbreaking for me to see that happen
so again i wasn't there right i can't
confirm or deny
uh as in most things that are
controversial uh
there's your side and then there's
people who would yell and scream and say
all kinds of other stuff but i think
it's important
for people to hear your perspective as
to what happened at that situation
and so coming out of that um you
and a number of other people decide uh
okay
there's going to be limited block size
moving forward
talk a little bit about how uh that
process
ends up determining you know because
there's kind of like the internet debate
and then there's ultimately uh people
have to make a decision are there going
to be big blocks or small blocks and
like
how does that happen right some people
may think that like you go to a place
and actually vote with a piece of paper
obviously that's not how this works so
describe the process of how that
decision kind of gets cemented
and then what the ramifications of that
were yeah so there was lots of
negotiating between the the big block
and small block camp so to speak and so
like
uh initially and i i forget what bip
number it was now but like
there was a plan to like double the
block size every 18 months or something
all the way up to i think it was
two or eight gigabyte blocks in the
future and then like the small block is
no no that's way too big and so then
like there was some other you know plan
with the
lower cap closer in the future and then
like the one of the first like major
major
proposals that actually started to get
some traction was to just i think a
one-time increase to 20 megabytes
but the small blocker said no that's
that's way too big and then
the next compromise was okay we'll do uh
eight megabytes
and then they said no no that's too big
and then the next compromise was okay
we'll go
two four eight megabytes over the next
like five years or something like that
and they said no no that's too big and
then the the final compromise was okay
we'll go to two megabytes
and then uh even the two megabyte
compromise there's this thing called the
segwit2x agreement or new agreement
where
there's supposed to be segregated
witness and two megabyte block size
and for whatever reason and i wasn't
there in person when the agreement was
made
i think that everybody should have
agreed to do both at the same time but
for whatever reason they agreed that
segwit would happen first and then the
two megabytes would happen second like a
couple months later
and so what happened everybody agreed to
that you had 90 plus percent of the you
know hash rate all the businesses signed
off
um the segwit part happened smooth
everything was fine
and then the two megabyte as soon as the
segment happened there was this giant
uproar from a bunch of people on the net
saying don't do two megabytes you know
you had people
posting photos of them all you know
holding axes with bandanas around their
faces and just all this you know
crazy nemours on the internet uh and
then eventually the memories were so
wild and crazy that the the two
megabytes
part didn't happen and so at some point
before that though and i had
nothing to do with this supply and
there's plenty of lies about me on the
internet but
probably the biggest lie is that i
created bitcoin cash uh the truth of the
matter is i had
absolutely nothing to do with the
creation of bitcoin gash
i i hardly even knew that it had been
created at all to be honest uh
i had zero to do with the creation and i
don't even think i was aware like when
the genesis block of the bitcoin cash
split had happened i i i think i found
out maybe a couple of weeks later and i
was kind of keeping an eye on it in the
side and then it wasn't until the two
megabyte part
failed with the segwit2x agreement which
was months after
after bitcoin cash had already existed
that's when i said well
it doesn't look like bitcoin is going to
scale to be money for the world
with a one megabyte block size the next
best looking
opportunity to bring more economic
freedom to the world and all the
wonderful things that enables looks to
me to be
bitcoin cash so that's when i focused my
time and effort on bitcoin cash but i
had zero to do with the creation of
bitcoin cash okay
so um for again i'm gonna try to
dumb down a lot of what you just said
for folks um
is basically the argument ended up being
there was the
bitcoin cash community that for all the
technical reasons that roger described
believed that you could solve scaling on
a layer one
technology move forward the legacy
um bitcoin if you will um or what is
called bitcoin today
uh is a belief that there is layer 1
layer 2 and
onwards and scaling can be done on other
layers
now again i'm i'm heavily over
generalizing this
because i want to kind of not get into a
super technical
things i think we'll lose a lot of
people and if i can clarify one small
thing so
both the small blockers they believe
that you can scale with layers on top of
bitcoin
the big blockers also believe that you
can scale with layers on top of bitcoin
but they don't believe in strangling the
base layer
whereas the small blockers want to limit
the base layer and only have layers on
top
the big blockers want to do both so to
kind of
zoom out even further before we go into
this next part is
basically what you have is um when you
look at bitcoin
there is a belief that having
the block size constrained allows anyone
to run a full node
and then you're going to get scalability
through layers on top
when you look at bitcoin cache there is
the ability to have an expansive block
size
that may or may not lead to only people
with
access to expensive computers being able
to run the nodes but you can
have scalability uh through layers as
well so that's kind of where we are at
the moment
um and if i can add one additional
interesting
fact related to that too if you go back
to and look at the internet archive
and look at bitcoin.org from 2011 or
2012 or 2013 and look at the faq over
there
they literally go over all the math with
what the current internet speeds are in
the world and the current cpu speeds are
and a hard drive costs
and they explain they give you the math
on the bitcoin.org website from 2011 12
or 13
as to how bitcoin on chain through
bigger blocks could scale to be money
for the entire world so
if you look at that bitcoin cash much
more closely resembles
what was on the bitcoin website in 2011
than
the current version of what everyone's
calling bitcoin which i think is an
important thing for people to realize
because i think a lot of people
maybe thought that the plan had always
been to to limit the the base
layer uh and then only have layers on
top and it's
it's also worth pointing out the
companies that did that the lightning
labs and the the
block streams the products that those
companies are selling
only have a market if you limit the the
base layer
if you don't limit the base layer
we're going to get that kind of is what
i'm saying yeah we're going to get to
all this
so um one of the things that people
watching
may be like wait a second roger you're
one of the most
uh well-known people in the space um
this fork of bitcoin cash happens
how could you not have known or how
could no one have told you about it
um talk a little bit about um because i
think that this is probably one of the
areas where
um you know i don't know the answer
right frankly you're probably one of the
only people who knows the answer
um if i think of like the devil's
advocate was sitting here talking to you
what they would say is roger helped
create this and and he created all this
stuff
and you know yada yada whatever your
argument is like look i didn't even
know i wasn't involved help people kind
of understand like
how is that possible and then also um
at what point did you come across
bitcoin cash and start to realize wait a
second this is worth spending more time
on
right because there's almost this
element of like
it sounds like there was issues with
bitcoin that or things that were
happening that you disagreed with
and so that then sent you looking
somewhere else so kind of talk just
through that transition for you
and kind of how did that occur and what
was the information you were consuming
at the time or thinking through
yeah so i think a lot of people today
don't realize it but early on
nobody cared about altcoins at all like
all coins were just
like totally off the radar bitcoin had
you know 90 plus percent market share
nobody cared about any altcoin for
anything at all it wasn't even and
even on my radar like i hardly cared at
all like i i should have taken
uh taken part in the ethereum ipo but i
didn't i i waited until it was still
like you know seven or eight bucks which
still did all right for me but uh
should have bought it at the ipo but you
know you win some you lose some
but nobody cared about any of this at
all until
bitcoin's user experience started to
degrade because of things like replace
by fee
and the high fees that were caused being
caused by the blocks starting to fill up
and that's when people started to look
at altcoins and they started to look at
things you know like dash and monaro and
zcash and
there started to be this you know whole
wave of people like hey i can start an
altcoin that can improve on some of the
problems that bitcoin is having so
mainly you know privacy fees you know
transaction reliability these sorts of
things
but before that nobody cared about it at
all and so people and so bitcoin had 90
plus percent market share uh and it
wasn't until the user experience of
bitcoin started to degrade
that people started divesting some of
their money that used to be in bitcoin
into altcoins myself included so that's
why i bought some ethereum that's why i
bought someone air that's why i bought
some dashes because
the future roadmap for bitcoin wasn't
looking bright in terms of having a good
user experience
okay so are you making the argument
and i'm trying to understand to make
sure that i kind of understand your
thought process
are you making the argument that people
started to divest from bitcoin into
things like ethereum because they
thought ethereum could be a bitcoin
replacement
or was it something else driving them
being interested in ethereum or other
all coins
i think mainly the first one so even
even vitalik the creator of
ethereum he would have built it probably
all on bitcoin but he looked at bitcoin
and the block size and opera turn wars
which is a little bit there's you know
whole other videos on that but basically
there people were already starting to
argue about
should we restrict the block size on
bitcoin and vitalik saw
the restrictions starting to happen on
bitcoins they said well i guess i won't
build ethereum on bitcoin
i'll build it on my own chain and so in
other people like everybody knows about
the ico boom
all that happened on ethereum all of
that would have happened
on bitcoin if it wasn't for the bitcoin
core developers
limiting the size of the operating data
and so for people that's getting a
little bit techy but to describe that
all these tokens that are on ethereum
everyone knows you know ethereum erc20
tokens all of that was starting to
happen on top of bitcoin
there were these things called colored
coins and a group of guys called
counterparty and they had a protocol
doing tokens on top of bitcoin and then
it was
really started to take off and lots of
stuff was starting to happen and then
the bitcoin core developers
chopped and reduced the amount of space
the data that people could put in the
operation of bitcoin which basically
just
gutted this entire token ecosystem that
was starting to bloom on top of bitcoin
and so all this entire ico stuff would
have happened on top of bitcoin had not
been for
for that what i think was a mistake off
on bitcoin's part
so that decision let's go back to flip
around the table what is their argument
as to why they did that and why was a
good thing
uh it was the exact same argument there
they said they want people to be able to
run
a full node on a really cheap computer
on a really horrible internet connection
in in you know rural rural south dakota
or you know to take your place
as people are going to see this ends up
being one of the key points
of difference of opinion that drives all
kinds of different decisions is
is running a full node individually at
the lowest level in terms of
cost and infrastructure a necessity
or something that uh could be kind of a
nice to have right so
that repeats itself over and over and
over again over the years
when we go to bitcoin cash um
you decided hey i'm going to
take some percent of the the
money and wealth that i have and i'm
going to put it into bitcoin cash to
start to migrate that way
um talk a little bit about the decision
you made kind of how did you come up
with
i don't think you sold all of your
bitcoin but you sold some of it and kind
of
why some not all and then
percentage-wise how did you think about
that
yeah so i'm i'm not a good trader i'm
not good at timing the market i'm a
long-term value investor i look at the
things that i think are going to be
useful long-term
but the main reason that happened is
because i up to that point i've been
telling every single person i meet if i
get in a taxi i'm going to tell the taxi
driver about bitcoin
and i'm going to give him some bitcoin
for free right and like anybody
everywhere in fact
you know losses some of the taxi drivers
just pay me everything in bitcoin like
it was really
interesting because i could tell people
yeah this money you can send and receive
with anyone anywhere in the world
instantly
basically for free no one can freeze
your account nobody can block it nobody
can control it in any way
and it's so fast super easy and reliable
to use
and when the blocks became full that
pitch wasn't there i would now have to
tell people hey there's this thing
called bitcoin
you can pay sometimes it's ten dollars
sometimes it's a dollar sometimes it's
fifty dollars in fees
sometimes the transactions go through
kind of fast sometimes it takes two
weeks on average
sometimes they can be reversed
how can i how can i be excited about
that right i couldn't be excited about
that so i needed
if i wanted to have anything to do with
cryptocurrency anymore
i'd need to be able to tell somebody
about a cryptocurrency that's actually
exciting and interesting and useful
to people and and bitcoin cash had it
with its fast cheap reliable
transactions uh
even if you you know couldn't
potentially run it on a raspberry pi on
a crappy internet connection somewhere
so let me ask there's two pieces here
that i think are important so obviously
bitcoin at some point um was
similar to bitcoin cash in terms when
you say fast cheap all these things
um and there was much less people using
it then
then at the point where you're saying uh
it was slower
it had higher fees whatever on the layer
one um one were you ever worried that
bitcoin
cash would run into the same thing there
was very few people using in the
beginning but over
a number of years if it became popular
there would be issues
and the second piece of this is i
actually go
backwards to kind of analyze this and
the way that i think about it
is gold was money for
thousands of years it's not very
portable it's not very divisible
it actually sucks as a medium of
exchange in terms of
you know if you've got to shave off gold
or kind of do anything like that
in order to improve that people built
paper claims on the gold rights kind of
a dollar backed by the gold eventually
they built electronic money
credit and kind of all these layers up
on top of uh that gold
now as we already discussed and kind of
agree on
maybe removing the gold from the dollar
was not the smartest decision it led to
all these issues
but history has kind of repeated itself
where
over a long period of time uh people
would push a currency to become
more efficient more usable etc is this a
situation where
you thought okay understand the argument
of there's going to be future layers on
top of bitcoin
and that could make it more usable but i
don't agree that that is the right
solution
or was it a thing where hey that might
work
but timing is important and so we need
to be able to do this now but that's
going to take too long to actually build
out
like was it a that's not possible or was
it
that's not ready today and therefore
that's why i'm
i need to go somewhere else yeah so
definitely the second part there so like
i hope lightning works but it's not
usable today and in fact if anything it
seems like
ethereum's winding up being bitcoin's
layer two scaling solution like there's
way there i think
several times more bitcoin is wrapped on
ethereum than there are you know total
liquidity in the lightning
network but to go back to about gold
but just i just want to make sure that i
got this so it wasn't hey
layer two layer through there for on a
bitcoin can't work
it's just i don't it's not ready they
weren't ready they're still not ready
yeah so basically it was a it was a
timing thing not a possibility thing
right which i think is exactly the
timing thing we need to rush because the
politicians are going to do everything
they can to keep the dollar as the
world's reserve currency
they don't want some you know
non-government-controlled currency to
become
the world's you know reserve currency
that everybody's using in commerce is
both
the medium of exchange and a store value
they want that to be the dollar they
want to be whatever is controlled by the
government
and so if we move quickly to get a mass
adoption it'll be too late for
governments to stop it but now we're
already starting to see that
the number one you know cryptocurrency
is is tether at this point
like hold up hold on hold on hold on
let's stay focused hold on
so as this is happening you decide okay
bitcoin cash and bitcoin you take what
percent of the bitcoin that you had at
that point and move it over into bitcoin
cash
uh i i don't remember uh and and prior
to that
it was a significant percentage double
good percentage right
but even before that i had been
concerned about bitcoin scaling so
that's why
i bought a bunch of ethereum i bought a
bunch of dash i bought a bunch of monero
i bought a bunch of zcash and zcoin and
on and on and on
i diversified into the cryptocurrencies
that i thought would give people
the best user experience uh and so
it wasn't only bitcoin cash the other
thing that i think is important here uh
if anyone is not aware of this roger's
not talking about like a million dollars
worth of bitcoin at the time right in
2015 16 and 17
um i believe you had hundreds of
thousands of bitcoin um
and the decisions that you're making
here are involving
you know tens of millions of dollars if
not more in terms of when you're
deciding to
move out of bitcoin into something else
right right
got it okay and so when you go ahead and
you move
some portion you know double digit
percentage whatever that ends up being
into bitcoin cash you're also
simultaneously doing that with other
um tokens what is kind of the
early days of roger bear with bitcoin
cash look like right
and from the outsider's perspective it
almost looks like you kind of did
exactly what you had been doing
with bitcoin right you kind of ran
around the world telling people about
electronic payments and kind of all the
things now it was
uh you were using bitcoin cash rather
than bitcoin
as the thing that you would send them or
the wall you'd give them or whatever is
that
fair to say yeah there was a little bit
more work to be done
because when this split happened or when
you there was the one single bitcoin and
then you had bitcoin cash and bitcoin
bitcoin cash had all the characteristics
that made bitcoin popular to begin with
but the thing that everybody's calling
bitcoin today had all the infrastructure
even though it didn't have the good user
experience so on the bitcoin cash side
even though it had the good user
experience
we had to rebuild all the infrastructure
that was that was lacking because we
lost it all at the time this split so
that's
still an ongoing process to this very
day and it's still a a catch-up game
okay
so so we'll we'll get to all that in a
few minutes here but
as this was occurring um
it's a little weird i think right uh
because
you were bitcoin jesus right like
literally you had spent
years and years of your life um and very
effectively
promoting bitcoin talking about it
pushing it um
and what i a lot of people may not
realize is you'd also make tons of
investments in the space not just in
bitcoin but in all sorts of
infrastructure and so one of those
things is bitcoin.com you had a bunch of
other things that you had
spent time on and so as you start to
transition
how did you think about um all of that
infrastructure right was it something
where in your head you said hey look
i've got to go now
get all of the investments that i've
made there to kind of switch over and
use bitcoin cash
was it something where look i don't
think i'm going to be able to do that so
actually what i want them to do is kind
of coexist and support both but like
what was the thought process given that
you still had these financial interests
in a bunch of infrastructure
um and you also had exposure to bitcoin
cash
and bitcoins you didn't sell all the
bitcoin right so how did you kind of
think about those two things and how
they would um
intersect with uh the equity investments
or the infrastructure investments that
you had made
yeah i think each each individual you
know i even when i invest in a company
i'm not the owner
the big owner of the company right the
ceo gets to decide what they're going to
do and what they're going to focus on
i think at the end of the day the
businesses are going to focus on the
things that are the most useful to their
their users or their customers
and so anybody that you know that's
listening this if you haven't
if you're on the fence or you don't know
or if you haven't tried using bitcoin
cash
try using it try using ethereum try
using ripple try using everything
and then use whatever is the most useful
to you in your own life you don't have
to be like
some tribal guy and like there's some
comic where they ask oh do you believe
in the trinity oh yes do you believe in
the resurrection
yes yes yes and they get to like some
really remote you know detail of like
you know way down religion like oh my
god heretic and they're gonna fight and
it's just like i feel like that's a lot
of it
the same sort of stupidity in the
cryptocurrency space i think all of us
are trying to build or at least most of
us are trying to build the tools
to empower individuals to have more
control over their own lives if you're
excited about that
bitcoin cash adds to that bitcoin adds
to that
ripple as that all of these add to that
so the more tools that people have in
the world to have more control over
their own lives
that's a good thing don't hate on them
go and go and cheer for them
all right so here's the part that i
think uh
before i'd ever met you talk to you
anything was the most confusing was
exactly the statement you just said
which is you're still a fan of bitcoin
bitcoin cash and many many other things
right
and so help people understand and
unpack that a little bit right where
somebody who was so convicted on bitcoin
obviously now is a big proponent of
bitcoin cash
and there's plenty of people who agree
disagree whatever what i always tell
people is like look
there's points of view in the world the
market will ultimately determine whoever
is right on this stuff
but what i find fascinating and is very
rare in the world frankly is somebody
who
um can have a belief in something
right so for you bitcoin cash um and
you're still able to intelligently talk
about and have some level of conviction
in bitcoin obviously right you still
hold bitcoin
um and these other things so just unpack
that because
i think when people see that that's just
a confusing thing right of like
why still have bitcoin and bitcoin cash
and like how do you think about
having exposure to both yeah so uh and
any good investor has a diverse
portfolio
and it's like i've seen you know a
couple of these bitcoin max was saying
why don't you sell all your bitcoins
like well i still have some dollars too
right i still have gold i still have
silver i still have
other you know stocks like have a
diverse portfolio like
selling putting all of your net worth
into one thing that's that's a
that's bad investment advice so but in
regards to the the bit
why why bitcoin and bitcoin cash well if
you look at bitcoin
it has this amazing network effect you
know tens of millions of users around
the world
the biggest market cap the most
liquidity uh and this you know worldwide
name recognition where people all over
the world if you go to the guy on the
street if you heard about bitcoin
they'll say yes if you go to the guy in
the street and say have you heard of
ethereum
they're probably gonna say no right and
uh and so bitcoin has this amazing
network effect
but it also has this horrible user
experience if you try and use it for
payments the payments are slow
expensive and unreliable and so then you
look at bitcoin cash if you go up to
somebody in the street and say have you
heard of bitcoin cash
they'll say well is is that different
than bitcoin like
they won't they won't be sure uh and so
it has less liquidity a lower market cap
less name recognition
but it has this amazing user experience
with lightning fast transactions that
are a fraction of a penny
and are irreversible and work you know
go through reliably all the time
and now you can make tokens on top of
bitcoin cash as well in like 30 seconds
then you can send
on-chain dividend payments to the token
holder so the tokens act like
anonymous bearer shares that are able to
receive dividend payments like
i think a lot of people don't realize
how big of a deal the token ecosystem on
bitcoin cash is you have
tether is now on top of bitcoin cash
with an slp token like there's a lot
happening
all right hold on so this is one of the
key i think differences of opinion and
this isn't something that i think people
will find
religious in nature like in terms of
emotional this is played out
over and over and over again for decades
in technology right what you just
described
is the difference between uh market
forces and technology right and so
i'm gonna go backwards again to go
forwards which is if you go back to vhs
versus betamax right there's a lot of
people who'd argue betamax was the
better technology
vhs got adopted and even though it was
inferior technology it ended up being
the winner
um because of all the reasons why people
have studied and there was adoption
now if you fast forward that to this
bitcoin bitcoin cash
i'm going to say that um regardless of
your or my opinion
is in terms of what ends up winning i
think that the two arguments can be
categorized as
uh you would argue that bitcoin cash has
superior technology which leads to that
better user experience in your opinion
and ultimately that will drive adoption
which will lead to the market
determining bitcoin cash wins
i think that there's a another argument
which is um
you can debate what technology is
superior or not superior
but the network effect of money and the
belief system of money and the adoption
that bitcoin already has
will continue to carry it to be the
winner and then that
adoption buys you the time to backfill
and build the technology necessary to
make it this global scalable thing
would you agree or disagree with the
categorization of those two arguments
i think very very well put uh
fantastically well put and that's why i
hold bitcoin and bitcoin cash today
because you should have some of both
so if you don't know which is gonna win
out for those two paths
so what i would say to that right and i
think that this is kind of
and part of why uh i want to do this
again was that we can kind of very
intelligently identify like
a point of disagreement right your your
perspective is hey
i have diversified exposure to bitcoin
cash and bitcoin
either one wins you win right i think
that
i go the opposite direction which is um
history has shown that
the adoption ends up being the winning
strategy right is there a possibility
that uh i am incorrect there's a
possibility that both of us are
incorrect and digital currency doesn't
end up being successful right
what i think though is when i look at
the probability
of if you gave me the choice to invest
in technology
or in the market adoption right as an
investor
even outside of digital currencies i'll
always choose the market adoption right
that's just
how i think about this stuff how i've
always thought about it and so i think
for people who are watching this
one of the key elements to the
disagreement and all this stuff
is that exactly right is does the
technology buy
time for the market adoption or does the
market adoption buy time for building
the technology
so the second thing that i want to talk
about is
as you move past that point then we get
to this world of
um the infrastructure itself right
and i think that um when you look at the
computing power
talk about how you think about the
importance of the computing power
actually running these networks
how you see bitcoin cash today versus
bitcoin and if there is a world where
bitcoin cash ended up being successful
in the future how would that
transition occur or maybe you would even
argue it doesn't need to occur
like just talk a little bit about the
actual computing networks and
and the differences there today and kind
of how you would see that playing out in
the future
i i don't know if i fully understand the
question but i kind of view it like
for those that are old enough to
remember my space before facebook
myspace was incredibly popular it had a
huge network effect
and then myspace started having the
equivalent of you know slow
unreliable uh and expensive in terms of
time you had to wait transactions
transactions meaning page loads on the
site so when the true in the user
experience on
myspace became slow expensive and
unreliable there was a mass migration to
to facebook and i think we could see the
exact same thing happen with everybody
that's trying to use bitcoin for
anything
commerce related uh you could see a mass
my group
so let's comment on that which is um
and i have a uh an unfair advantage over
you because i worked at facebook and we
obviously spent way too much time
obsessed with why did myspace fail
um the one thing that i'm hearing like
please yeah well
the one difference between myspace and
facebook and uh i think zuck would be
the first one to
uh admit that like i don't know if they
necessarily knew what they were doing
when they created the news feed itself
but with myspace it was a directory of
people so you could go and you could go
to people's different pages and all this
stuff
the thing that facebook did that
actually locked people into the network
was the news feed
now you just went to the news feed and
everyone's content got put there and so
it was less of
roger go navigate to all of your friends
pages and check to see what they're up
to and it was more of now facebook has
this like integrated
experience and so uh i've heard people
argue
it doesn't matter for this conversation
you know myspace didn't have network
effect because you saw the
navigate to all the different pages they
just had a lot of users and facebook
really got the network effect and they
ended up winning
neither here nor there for this um what
i think though that
i hear you saying and confirm for me is
today bitcoin has
a network effect naturally money's super
viral product right in whatever form it
is
and it's got the market share it's got
the the kind of name recognition
whatever
but i think your argument is you can
break a network effect
if the product itself never meets
expectations and people will eventually
migrate somewhere else
and you feel like there's some
percentage chance that happens is that a
fair
characterization yeah i think there's a
pretty darn good percentage chance that
that happens and the user experience for
payments on bitcoin is so bad today
what number would you put on it
it's probably somewhere in the ballpark
of 50 would be my guess and so
david freeman is an economist i really
like and he always says look at the
actions people take rather than the
words they say so if you look at the
actions that i've taken like
my btc versus bch portfolio position
it's somewhere in the ballpark of 50 50
in terms of you know dollar value
uh so so my actions help
lead me to even if i my word i'm telling
you what my with my words what my
actions have been
i think it's somewhere in the ballpark
of 50 50 between those two but then i
also have nice positions in ethereum and
ripple and dash and
you know on and on and on so because i
don't think we know what the the winner
is guaranteed to be in the end
okay so um and i want to be as
respectful of your time but i i know
that you've kind of committed to let's
have
the full conversation here um one of the
things that
uh i wanna i wanna always play a game
right and i read through all these
twitter threads and as i told you i took
out every single troll and meme and all
this stuff
and frankly uh uh they were coming at me
as much as you
right so so kind of kind of we were in
the same boat of under attack by the
meme lords
uh but but what i pulled out was a bunch
of questions that i would consider
the um the negative view of roger or the
negative view of bitcoin cash and
what i want to do is i want to ask you
the questions and then allow you just to
respond right and kind of it's not for
me to make a judgment in many cases it's
more of i
want people to be able to ask the
questions that um they have
you respond and then people can decide
you know how they how they feel from
this
um the first one we already addressed
which was like why do you still own
bitcoin right i think they kind of
you clearly articulated that um the
second one is
uh why is bitcoin uh
cash usage so low and part of that
also being why are bitcoin blocks
consistently
bigger than bitcoin cash so kind of i
think those two things are related
talk through kind of how you look at
that and explain it
and then kind of what you think about
that moving forward
yeah so um there's two questions there
so why are big
bitcoin cash blocks smaller than bitcoin
box because there's more transactions
happening on bitcoin every day than on
bitcoin cash
so far but in terms of why are so few
people using bitcoin cash that's not
true at all bitcoin cash depending on
the day
is the second or third most transacted
in chain in terms of the number of
dollars being moved
in the native token on chain so it's
bitcoin it's number one and then
depending on the day it's bitcoin cash
or ethereum uh sometimes bitcoin cash
has even more value moved on it
than ethereum does so like that's a
really really big deal so
uh bitcoin cash is widely used around
the world and when you go to bitcoin.com
there's lots of tools to help people
use bitcoin cash because it it really
really works okay
so um and again this goes under the like
the part that i like about this
conversation
is there's a couple of key themes and
we're going to keep revisiting them
through all these different
these questions that goes under the
market adoption is in the favor of
bitcoin today
your belief is you think it'll switch
the bitcoin cash there's obviously a
bunch of people who think it'll save
bitcoin right
the next question is uh do you run a
bitcoin node
um still at all um i have a
btc and a bch node that i can boot up
from time to time and sync with the
network i don't leave it on all the time
but i do have those nodes yeah okay
um another question was um
how many bitcoin cash nodes are yours
so myself personally i have the one that
i can boot up and sync from time to time
the bitcoin.com business i it probably
has a few i'd have to ask the different
tech guys how many we have but i would
guess
with the mining pool and everything else
between 10 and 20 maybe around the world
would be my guess
okay um another question was
um let's see here what are the metrics
that you
use to uh evaluate the success
of bitcoin or bitcoin cash like what are
the things that you think are most
important
in terms of determining whether
something is working or not
fantastic question so uh objective
values would be like how much commerce
is happening on chain how much money is
being moved
on chain how many transactions what's
the average value of those transactions
um the more emotional answer to that is
like
how empowering is this tool for more
people around the world to have more
control over their own lives and that
that one it's a bit
harder to to put a concrete number on or
an objective
standard but uh if you look at people in
third world countries
they're not going to be able to figure
out how to set up a lighting node
they're not going to be able to figure
out how to use any of these layer 2
stuff
they're either going to use bitcoin cash
on chain or a custodial bitcoin solution
where they're just
you know someone else has their private
keys and at their mercy of having their
account frozen it's going to be one one
of those two choices
okay um in terms of
bitcoin cash when you think about
that that future migration right so
market is winning in terms of market has
adopted
bitcoin that's where the name
recognition is all that stuff
frankly a lot of that is due to the
early work that you had right
in terms of going out and really talking
about this and spending so much time and
educating people and driving adoption
um what would it take on the bitcoin
cash side
for you to say look i'm 50 50 right now
like
actually this isn't gonna work and you
know give up
it has like a negative connotation to it
but basically just come to the the
realization or identify
hey bitcoin cash is and is not going to
be the solution because
it's not a tech then market thing okay
the market's going to be the the most
important thing
and then you know uh walk away from
bitcoin cash i guess
people asked in all kinds of different
ways but that's essentially what they're
asking
yeah bitcoin would have to start being
more usable as peer-to-peer electronic
cash
enabling more economic freedom around
the world than bitcoin cash
and it's not even close at the moment
but maybe that'll change in the future
okay and and i think that uh if i had
somebody here like if i had two
technical people one from bitcoin cash
and one from bitcoin
the two arguments would be again layer
one
scalability with the potential to add
layers to and above
on bitcoin cache on the bitcoin side
it's
layer one constraint block sizes
scalability comes from layer two etc
as you said you're unhappy with kind of
the layer two
examples today but that's the the
opportunity if you like everything it'll
get better over time but it's questions
how much time and so on that front i
would love to recommend i think you'd be
a fantastic host for that with an open
mind and and respectful demeanor
uh peter risen the chief scientist of
bitcoin unlimited
i'm sure would love to participate uh
and he'd be you know the big block
advocate there and i think would be
fantastic you could get uh
elizabeth stark of lightning labs and
they can they can both discuss
the pros and cons of the lightning
network or or adam back the founder of
blockstream i think
uh either elizabeth or adam would be a
fantastic person to have a discussion
with uh
peter risen on layer two solutions peter
risen wrote some really interesting
essays
about why he's not bullish on the
lightning network
uh in the short term and i think that
would be incredibly interesting and i
know i'd love to watch that discussion
uh but from what i've heard so far the
adam back and elizabeth stark don't seem
to be willing to have that conversation
um which to me makes me wonder are their
arguments not that strong if they're not
willing to have that conversation but uh
for any of them that wind up hearing
this or if you know those people ask
them to do it because i think all of us
all over the world would be able to
learn a lot from watching and listening
to that conversation
so another question um is
how do you think through um again
the market cap the number of payments
transactions all that stuff
why do you think people are still using
bitcoin
even with the issues that you've
described right so so if the issues are
are
that big of a deal and you're basically
um you think there's a 50
chance that people will end up leaving
bitcoin moving to bitcoin cash
what's keeping them there is it just a
network effect type thing
or is there other things that that you
kind of um
rationalize in your head as to why
they're staying there and really what i
think this question is getting at is
like
uh i had ross gerber come on who's a big
tesla bull right
and i asked him i said well what did the
bears believe that you were able to
recognize but you just disagreed with
him
what was ross's answer to that on tesla
because tesla's been on a wild ride
yeah well so he's been right right and
he actually had a pretty good answer in
terms of how he
walked through exactly the work he did
to get convicted he went to dinner with
uh kind of the tesla bears and you know
did all the work and then he was just
like
i just think they're wrong on and he had
a couple of things you know in terms of
what those things were i think this
question is getting at
why are people staying with bitcoin if
there's still all the technical
uh issues that uh that you've described
yeah so i i think the answer to that
question is
you can look at it in terms of market
cap so bitcoin cash's market cap is uh
somewhere in the ballpark of five
billion dollars and bitcoin's market cap
is you know
somewhere close to 200 billion dollars
or some much bigger number
so you have you know 200 billion dollars
versus a capital of capital versus 5
billion
worth of capital the people with the 5
billion in bitcoin cash are motivated to
see bitcoin cash succeed
but you have almost 200 billion dollars
worth of capital and bitcoin that are
motivated to see bitcoin succeed so
that's a
that's a that's a lot of capital out
there that it's in favor of you know
seeing bitcoin succeed but if people
start seeing the writing on the wall
of things like you know bitcoin not
being usable in commerce and i don't
have the data in front of me but i think
the average transaction size on bitcoin
at the moment is something like fifteen
hundred dollars
uh if you're somebody that needs you
know cheap fast reliable payments and
you live in a you know
a low-income country bitcoin's not very
useful to you uh as of yesterday
the average fee on the bitcoin network
to get included in the next vlog is five
dollars right
five dollars that's a lot of money to
people in a lot of first world countries
uh the average fee to be included in the
bitcoin cash block is less than a penny
that's fine for anybody anywhere in the
world so i think uh
part of part of this right and um uh i i
i'll paraphrase the quote but it's uh
yogi berra says
uh oh nobody ever goes to that
restaurant because it's too crowded
right you're too crowded or you know
whatever it is right and i think like
ultimately like that's kind of what this
whole debate gets to
is um the reason why some of these
issues come up is because everyone's
using it
right and everyone being still a small
group of just cryptocurrency enthusiasts
whatever
but it sounds like um
that's the thing that in order for
bitcoin cash to succeed would have to
change is that fair
yeah yeah you'll need more more people
using things but uh
it is true when a restaurant's too
crowded people go to other restaurants
that would have originally gone to that
uh
first restaurant and i think that's
exactly what happened with bitcoin is it
could have accommodated a whole lot more
people like
honestly i think that the market uh the
price of bitcoin today
could have easily already been a hundred
thousand dollars per single bitcoin
if it didn't run into the scaling
disaster that drove away you know
businesses like microsoft
stopped accepting bitcoin dell computer
stopped accepting bitcoin
bitcoin jesus stopped promoting bitcoin
and that's how big of a deal
this scaling problem was with bitcoin so
so there would be some people who would
be willing to admit and i don't know
what percentage of bitcoin
would say this which would say uh the
scaling debate
that the final result ended up in a
place where they didn't agree with it
right so for whatever reason they
thought that there should be bigger
blocks blah blah whatever
but they still believe that bitcoin will
succeed in spite of
those decisions so it's a thing where
hey we were on this trajectory we made
some decisions
they would argue that uh we made a
detour but like we're eventually still
gonna end up at the same place maybe we
just took a detour on the way
i think the argument that you would have
and correct me if i'm wrong
is uh hey those decisions ended up being
much more than a detour and therefore i
chose to to basically get another car
right um what do you say to the people
who just think it's
like a detour type deal but ultimately
bitcoin will still be successful
whether you agree with those decisions
or not the people that think it's just
just a delay uh they very well may be
right uh i i don't know if it
i don't know if getting in there another
and i didn't get you know i have one
foot in the bitcoin cash car and one for
the bitcoin car and one in ethereum and
everywhere else but uh the frustrating
part though is no matter what whether
whether you know it's going to be a
different car that gets to the finish
line or the bitcoin car
just gets there later whichever car gets
to the finish line first it's going to
get there later than it otherwise would
have and that's the most frustrating
part to me like we could have had this
amazing peer-to-peer electronic cash for
the world sooner
uh instead it's gonna wind up being
later than it otherwise would have been
if we hadn't run into that scaling uh
civil war within bitcoin that's the most
frustrating part for me
all right um one of the questions that i
absolutely loved uh and i only saw one
person ask it
which i i wish that more people would
ask it is when i talk to you
uh i see all the people with all the you
know they've got all the controversy
they
say all this kind of stuff it feels to
me like you still have
half your heart with bitcoin and half
your heart with bitcoin cash
but ultimately your heart is in
electronic payments and kind of this
um this finish line that we keep talking
about
where there's a world in the future that
will be much better than the world we're
in today
and so would it be fair to say that if
bitcoin cash was not successful
you would gladly kind of jump back on
the bitcoin bandwagon and start pushing
that forward
um or or maybe you found something else
that you thought would ultimately get
that but but
you're kind of tied to the mission of
getting to that future world
and you're trying to figure out what is
the best vehicle to get there
yeah absolutely i'll be the biggest
cheerleader i possibly can
for whichever tool i think is going to
be the one that gets us the fastest to
that future in which people have control
over their own money and don't need
permission from
you know banks or politicians to do what
they want with their own funds even if
it was bitcoin
if it's bitcoin yeah bitcoin ripple dash
if even if it was the us dollar somehow
i would
i started cheering the us dollar if i
thought come on don't be
crazy now so i i guess then that leads
to the question of like
what are the things that you would look
at um it's kind of a
i've been asked a bunch of times right
like what are the things that i would
identify as
uh would make bitcoin fail right and
i've got a whole list of
everything from self-inflicted wounds of
you know introducing bugs during the
software process to all kinds of things
i would look at
what are the things for you that when
you look at bitcoin cash
uh either would have to happen for you
to say okay you know
it didn't work or two or the metrics
where
whether it was liquidity or market cap
or something you would basically say oh
you know what maybe i actually need to
hedge more into something else
yeah great great question um
i think the thing that would make me
feel the most frustrated with bitcoin
cash is if it stopped being usable as
cash if it no longer had fast cheap
reliable payments
or something else that came along that
had fast cheap reliable payments
and an as big or even bigger network
effect because the network effect is a
really really big deal
uh i don't know if they're bots or if
they're real people but every anytime i
go on twitter i see a bunch of people
tweeting me
what about nano what about nano it's you
know and the honest truth is i don't
know about nano because i haven't really
come across its network effect other
than a bunch of people on twitter
tweeting about it but uh you know maybe
i'll spend an afternoon reading
in into nano but uh as far as i know you
know you can't really pay it with nano
at many websites and uh
i know very little about nano but like
the thing about bitcoin cash that's so
awesome
is it has just as many if not more
places that you can pay with it online
and offline uh than bitcoin in fact i
think almost for sure there's
more physical merchants where you can
pay with bitcoin cash than there is that
you can pay with bitcoin and that's
that's a real big deal
and that's a sign of the network effect
so so if you see the nano
uh tweeters wait till they start dming
you because they're
absolutely insane uh and i definitely
think that a lot of them are bots
um one of the things that i just wrote
down was
uh probably the most used word other
than bitcoin jesus to talk about you uh
in the threads was just scam
right and i think when people hear that
you know
it's easy to kind of get the mob out and
everyone gets their pitchforks and just
you know who are we yelling at today
right type thing especially in today's
society
um and so what i try to do is like why
right now i asked a bunch of people why
and they came up with a whole bunch of
different things and so i just kind of
want to walk through a couple of these
and
in fact they just let you respond right
which and the first one was
bitcoin.com as a url uh
promotes bitcoin cash so why not use
bitcoincash.com or something else
how do you think about the use of
bitcoin.com
um and then having bitcoin cash and
promoting it on there
yeah so bitcoin.com is my domain name
and i can promote whatever i want on it
i could turn it into
a site to promote the federal reserve if
i really wanted to it's my domain name
if you don't like it you can make me an
offer for the whole domain name i can
sell you the whole thing in the whole
business you can pay me a bitcoin cash
for it then you can do whatever you want
with it to
anybody out there that doesn't like what
we're doing with it currently so uh
that doesn't make it now you know i have
to ask what price would you sell it at
i think 22 million bitcoin cash would
get it
22 million bitcoin cash there's only 21
million ever
so got it and so
i guess what people would say is like
you're absolutely right
right in terms of um you're able to do
whatever you want and i love the example
like you can promote the federal reserve
on bitcoin.com and knock yourself out um
do you feel like um it's misleading
to promote something other than bitcoin
on there or how do you
like i guess if you went to a board
meeting right for bitcoin.com and you
were sitting there you were talking
about like hey here's why we make
certain decisions
like what is the logic behind the
decision
not can you do it of course you can do a
lot of things right
but like what is the logic and kind of
how do you think about the advantage
for bitcoin.com in doing so
i guess two two points there so if we
were to be promoting btc
on on bitcoin.com we'd be promoting an
inferior product that gives people a bad
user experience and every day
we still get user support requests hey
why didn't my transaction go through
hey you guys are ripping me off i had to
pay five dollars to send my bitcoin i
thought bitcoin was supposed to be you
know
free or cheap to send and like every day
we get people doing that and so
and even if you look at it historically
if we were promoting
btc that's not the bitcoin described in
the white paper that's not the bitcoin
described on bitcoin.org in 2010 2011
2012
2013 like the thing that everybody's
calling bitcoin today
it has the bitcoin name and it has the
bitcoin network effect but it doesn't
have the
the characteristics that made bitcoin
popular to begin with and it doesn't
have the
you know bitcoin cash has far more it
has all that except for
the most proof of work on the longest
chain but it has the fast cheap reliable
payments uh
if you read the white paper it's clearly
talking about something that more
closely resembles bitcoin cash
than bitcoin so i feel like if we were
to promote btc only on bitcoin
we'd be doing the entire world a
disservice like i think bitcoin cash can
bring more economic freedom to the world
faster than bitcoin can today
and um you guys right now do bitcoin and
bitcoin
cash on bitcoin.com yeah and in fact
like
our entire goal on bitcoin.com is to
make as clear as possible
the differences between bitcoin and
bitcoin cash because we want everybody
to know and understand the differences
because
we think if people understand the
differences we think they'll prefer
bitcoin cash just like myself
i understand the differences i prefer
bitcoin cash and i think that's part of
maybe that was what the reason that you
know our bitcoin and bitcointalk.org had
to engage in so much censorship they
were worried that if people
were able to hear both sides of the
arguments they would prefer the big
block side of the argument and that's
why they have to engage in the
censorship
all right hold on so on bitcoin.com
uh you're comfortable in terms of or
do you think people try to buy btc and
end up buying bch or vice versa like do
you think that people get confused
i i think very very few people if any
get confused uh
so no i don't think this problem because
we put it very very clearly
right there so people can see and we
have entire articles describing the
entire history and the differences
between both so
anybody that spends the time to even you
know do a little bit of research in the
topic and understand that btc and bch
are two different coins
with two different characteristics and i
don't think anybody's being fooled or
tricked
uh into you know buying one on accident
instead of the other if anything i think
if people buy btc thinking it's the
bitcoin described in the white paper
they're being fooled all right
so another thing i saw was somebody
tweeted a chart and i
apologized that i forget it was either
btc over bch or bch over btc
but basically it was showing that the
price appreciation of bitcoin
drastically outweighs the price movement
of
bitcoin cash and so basically you know
you said earlier like you're not a
trader
right and i'm in the same boat as you
i'm not a trader but
uh over what is now months if not you
know years
uh the bitcoin price has performed
differently than the bitcoin cash price
and so how do you think about those
price movements um
and do you worry at all about that as a
signal
i i think that uh that part of that's
because i'm such a horrible trader
right right after the split i'm like
didn't do any dollar cost averaging from
one into the other it's like hey let's
move quickly and let's move a lot and so
uh
at one point the price of bitcoin cash
was you know about half of bitcoin
so that means for any bitcoins i sold
that point i got two for one
whereas the current ratio is like 40 or
50 to one between bitcoin cash and
bitcoin so uh
you know any any bitcoin core people
that sold their their b
cash at that point you know you're
welcome you got a good deal on it uh
but i remember in 2012 the entire
bitcoin ecosystem was feeling really
discouraged
bitcoin 2011 got up to 30 and people
felt like you know we're on the moon
this is
fantastic and the price went from 30
down to a dollar and some change over
the next year and a half
and there are a lot of people think oh i
should get out before this goes to zero
and
no not me i was building and promoting
and building and
investing it's the same it's the same
phase in bitcoin cash right now all the
infrastructure's really starting to get
there
i'm still building i'm still investing i
you know we have our 250 million
bitcoin cash ecosystem fund i've
deployed about 15 million of that so far
we're deploying a couple million every
month here
uh it's a really big deal we're building
out this ecosystem
before you know and the overall number
of people using cryptocurrency around
the world is still small
right so bitcoin.com we're not trying to
reach existing crypto people
we're trying to build the tools for to
bring the rest of the entire world into
using crypto
and bitcoin cash is in a really good
position to be the onboard
ramp for all those people around the
world because it's fast cheap and
reliable that's what people want they
don't want to
you know have to calculate manually what
the fee ratio needs to be and what the
block time is going to be and
they just want something that works but
if we can build something that works
that's non-custodial where bitcoin.com
can't freeze their accounts and if we
get subpoenaed we don't have any
information
about what people have going on we can
provide privacy in the wallet so it's
fast cheap reliable and private and easy
to use
boom that's going to be a winning
combination for the world and i don't
see bitcoin having that it just has this
name recognition
and bigger market cap at the moment so i
promise people
if we did this live i would try to take
some of their questions and
two of the things you just said people
just went nuts with so
first is hub and feel free to not answer
if you want but but uh
people want to know how much value you
lost by being a bitcoin cash versus
bitcoin with the
with the funds that you diverted a lot
right
so like a bit you know at the high point
i think bitcoin cash was two to one and
now it's what 40 or 50 to one so
i didn't sell all of my bitcoin into
bitcoin cash at two to one but even if i
sold
even if i sold 10 right that's still a
big chunk of money right
and it was definitely more than 10. it's
uh a lot
okay and then the second thing is uh the
second you said
be cash everyone just went nuts uh so
talk a little bit about
be cash versus bitcoin cash and kind of
like um
why the preference of one over the other
and and kind of explain that
yeah so two i guess two points in there
so the first one so that where the
origin of the word be cash came
is a bunch of people that didn't like
the bitcoin
cash and big blocks and that fork of
bitcoin they went out and registered the
you know be cash twitter account and r
b cash on reddit and you know be
cash.com all these domain names and
social media accounts
and then had them all pre-populated and
set up with all sorts of negative
information
about bitcoin cash and the big block
movement and then they tried to convince
everybody that the name of bitcoin cash
would be be cash so that when people
would search for be cash they would see
all this negative content about it so it
was actually like
a social media attack and the people
that owned all the be cash
social media names are people who
actually hate bitcoin cash so
there's no way that bitcoin cash could
ever actually change its name to be cash
even though
be cash isn't a bad name it's it is an
easier name to say but if you if
if all the people that own all the
domain names and social media accounts
for be cash
hate bitcoin cash there's no way you
could ever switch to it so it was
actually part of a
social media attack and then there's the
other you know semi-world famous photo
of me you know giving the guy a middle
finger at one point
i invite everybody please watch the
entire interview it's like it's like an
hour long interview don't just watch the
40 second clip or whatever it is and you
know if you've ever watched ali g or
borat
that's what was going on the guy was
pushing my buttons for 45 minutes and
like
i shouldn't have lost my temper but
after 45 minutes of him pushing my
buttons i lost my temper and snapped and
i shouldn't have done that but like
that's what happened and it wasn't
because he called it
be cash the thing that pushed me over
the edge made me snap was when he
accused me
of having paid for a whole bunch of sock
puppets on the internet like me
maybe the nano guys are doing that i
don't have any proof but i have never
ever ever paid for anything like that
ever and in fact i've discouraged people
from ever doing it any time i've ever
heard of anything like that going on
and so when he just stated as a matter
of fact everybody knows that it's you
roger and all the stock puppets you're
paying for
the only people that like be cash uh
that's what set me over the edge it
wasn't him using the word be cash was
him accusing me of engaging in you know
psyops and you know the same sort of
crazy
propaganda governments engaging with you
know their 50 cent armies and
all this other crazy stuff so so two
follow-ups on that uh quick ones
one uh do you laugh at the photo now
like when you see it is it just kind of
like uh
it's stupid but at the same time like
it's almost uh one of these things where
i know a lot of people who
have become a meme to some degree they
just like whatever
no i it's probably my least i regret
that way more than like having you know
sold firecrackers and gone to prison
like that's
that's not the person that i am one bit
like i'm a passionate person
but i'm not an angry person i almost
never that's one of the few times
in my life that i've lost my temper uh
like that that's that's not who i am
at all and it's really really
disappointing to me when i see that you
know pretty much anytime i tweet
anything people reply to me on twitter
with that picture and it's really uh
it's really sad for me because that's
not the person that i am
at all i think that's a that's a very uh
sober rational view of it
um and the second piece is uh see
somebody keeps asking
uh how how do you handle all the stress
of people um
either you know again like i said like
one of the most popular words is scammer
right and you know i don't care who you
are as a human you just got to be like
this sucks right and so like how do you
handle the stress of
um community backlash or people
disagreeing or wanting to argue and kind
of all that stuff
all the time yeah i don't worry about it
one bit because i know the truth and the
truth is far more important than being
popular
and anybody who's been in the ecosystem
for a while too knows the truth as well
so
uh anybody that's busy calling me a
scammer or somebody who's been fooled by
uh by probably a bunch of sock puppets
on the internet because
don't underestimate the the the power of
you know social media influence if
everybody around you
tells you that santa claus is real you
believe it if everybody around you tells
you that roger's a scammer you're going
to believe it without evidence for
either one of those things
um i've got one more question and then i
kind of want to summarize our
conversation here but before i do that
uh if you're watching the live stream
please hit the like button so that more
people can watch this
uh it's super helpful for whatever
reason youtube's algorithm uh
enjoys that um one of the last questions
i have for you before we summarize kind
of the conversation
is uh satoshi you were really early in
bitcoin
um how do you think about who satoshi is
um
do you want to know who it is do you
know who it is just talk a little bit
about
satoshi yeah at one point
um i was fairly convinced that craig had
some role
in that uh
whoever or whatever satoshi is at this
point like i think he deserves his
privacy uh
if it were to be craig i would be uh
rather than improving my opinion of
craig it would just uh diminish my
opinion of satoshi substantially um
so yeah whoever compared fair to say you
don't think it's craig
yeah uh extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof and uh
if he were satoshi he could provide that
proof at any moment and he hasn't done
it yet so
uh no i don't i don't think he's satoshi
at this point okay
and then any idea as to who it could be
or
uh speculation on who it is
space aliens right i don't know
be careful in 2020 man
you guys the people listening this will
like this story on the early days of
bitcointalk.org there's a really fun
and interesting thread of people
discussing one people
the thread is like what's your favorite
thing about bitcoin and people were
talking about their favorite things
about bitcoin and one guy's favorite
thing about bitcoin was
that now when we finally make contact
with space aliens we don't have to be
embarrassed about the type of money
we're using anymore
and i thought that that was a pretty
interesting point
that's awesome um so last question about
satoshi is just uh
there's a lot of people who want to
speculate and kind of play the games of
you know who is it
do you do you want to know or do you
think it's actually better that
it's an unknown person or group there
was that other
video that came out a month or two ago
that made a really interesting
compelling case for adam back
having been satoshi and it made me it
definitely made me scratch my head a bit
and say hmm
uh yeah so uh and but do i want to know
no i think that's one of the things that
just kind of adds to the lure of all of
cryptocurrency in general is that it's
created by this mysterious figure and
everybody can imagine satoshi to be
the exact perfect person that they would
want him to be and the fact that we
don't know exactly who it is means that
nobody's gonna be mad at that person so
everybody can envision that oh
bitcoin was created by satoshi who
agrees with me on everything so he was
trying to create bitcoin
to be this exact perfect thing that i
wanted to be so it's fantastic from a
marketing standpoint
yeah and so kind of in summary i think
that uh
i want to just you know really wrap up
where i think um we agree and then where
we disagree um and disagree again has a
negative connotation but but it's really
just
a market bet right um and so as we
started the conversation like there's a
lot of issues in the world
both economically with the monetary
system and those lead into
other aspects of life that are just
broken right and there needs to be a
solution i think you would agree with
that
um and i think you and i are uh dead in
line
with that being a digital currency right
and and
at some point we need to have a
cryptocurrency become the global reserve
uh currency and that will drive a lot of
uh impact and improvement across the
world
where you get into kind of a difference
is you've got bitcoin you've got bitcoin
cash bitcoin cash has a very specific
view of the world and kind of the two
key things i think are one
uh superior technology in the eyes of
the bitcoin cash community will
ultimately lead to
adoption uh which will ultimately lead
to kind of
winning um and a key piece of that is
that everyone doesn't need to
uh run a bitcoin node right or that's
not as important as other aspects
i think in the bitcoin community um kind
of this constant
journey to make sure that anyone
anywhere can run a node
uh has always served as one of the core
key tenants
um and because it has all of the market
adoption or a lot of market adoption has
been the leader there
both for early work of yours and many
many other people
um regardless of any technical
limitations today
uh that market adoption gives a head
start and ultimately will allow
um bitcoin to um build out what it needs
to to kind of serve that function
did i miss anything in kind of the
categorization
of where there's a different oh
i think we might have lost roger let's
see if he comes back here
okay sorry about that oh all right no
problem uh what was the last thing that
you heard
i think you were talking about the
differences between bitcoin cash and
bitcoin
and then got it so uh basically what i'm
saying is bitcoin cash
um believes that uh in their eyes the
superior technology will lead to market
adoption market adoption leads to
you know quote unquote winning that race
uh and one of the key things
is that there's a belief that not
everyone needs to be able to run a node
or that's not the most important thing
uh on the bitcoin side um there's a you
know very heavy belief that anyone
anywhere should be able to run a bitcoin
node
uh and regardless of any technical
limitations they will eventually be
solved because
bitcoin's market adoption and network
effect uh will buy at the time to build
that out in layer 2 and
other technologies uh is that a fair
characterization in terms of how you see
um
kind of the two different uh really
narratives and
journeys playing out yeah i actually i
think that's a pretty pretty good
narrative
or pretty good characterization um but
head's your bets right you don't have to
put all your your
you know don't put all your money on one
horse here have some of each and
especially if you're one of those people
if you're you know consider if you
believe in the the first argument that
bitcoin
the the bigger market cap will overcome
the technological limitations that you
have currently
if you're not running a full node
yourself maybe that's an indication that
maybe the other the other path is okay
as well and the part that'll be so
frustrating for me
is if those layer twos never come into
use well enough and everybody's having
to use custodians well you're just right
back to what happened with the gold at
standard
and the dollar uh you know they got
separated now everybody's at the mercy
of the dollar
what what if that happens with uh you
know bitcoin everybody starts using
custodial solutions and before you know
it
look at mount cox they're running
fractional reserve for a long long time
uh maybe you know maybe for years and
years and years
who's to say you know maybe that's going
to happen with the coin bases or the
zappos or the other you know custodial
wallets out there in the world
that's a real big problem if you're
using a wallet in which you have custody
of the funds yourself
uh you don't have to worry nearly as
much about those other sorts of problems
and so would it be fair in saying that
ultimately the winner here and i always
tell people like my personal opinion
doesn't matter in the sense of like
what critical it wins right or what ends
up being the globally adopted thing
would you agree that it's just going to
come down to whatever the market
determines
yeah but the market is never done
determining is the other part of it too
like i see people on twitter saying
oh the market is decided the market's
never done deciding right iphone one at
one point was the number one thing in
the market well
it's not anymore right and the iphone 11
is one of the best the best iphone in
the market today it's not going to be
next year
uh so the market is never ever ever done
deciding even if bitcoin cash
were to wind up being the top
cryptocurrency that's not forever
right something and people always used
to ask me back in 2011 or 12 or 13 like
well what if something better than
bitcoin comes along and i always told
them
i hope something better than bitcoin
does come along because then we all get
to use it right it's a good thing if
something better than bitcoin cash comes
along
if something better than bitcoin cash
comes along we all get to use that too
so
the more things that are better than
what we have today that come along the
better the world is that we want as many
better and new things to come along as
we possibly can because that's how the
world
progresses into a better world so the
the one of the last things that i want
to talk about is uh
when we get done with this i'm going to
have a million people talk to me and
they're going to say what what is roger
bear's
view of the world right and um
one just thank you for spending the time
to go through this i wanted to do it
live so that people could
um kind of ask the questions and really
engage but
also i think my response to that would
be roger
spent a good number of years of his life
promoting bitcoin he sees this vision of
the future where digital currency ends
up creating
great things in the world he made a
decision to
divest or diversify about 50
of the bitcoin into bitcoin cash uh
that hasn't gone so well so far from a
financial return perspective
but his belief is that um at some point
in the future there's going to be a
divergence
or a loss of interest in bitcoin and
people will move to bitcoin cash
um the current market dynamics
roger would uh say show great adoption
for bitcoin
um but there's a belief that that will
change in the future
if i was to categorize it that way is
anything in there inaccurate
or do you feel like that's a pretty fair
view of the world as to kind of how you
see it
i i think i need to hire you to be my
new spokesperson here too such a fan
i'm staying on the bitcoin side so i see
all the people asking i don't know
bitcoin cash
that stuff but why let's ask you why why
don't why don't you
diversify again it comes back to when i
look at
um on twitter or is it a rational reason
not at all
it's it's look the fact that we're even
having this conversation right there's a
bunch of people who are all
upset and you know you saw the people
who get all uh worked up about it
i i generally think kind of three things
are really important right so
when it comes to non-financial
non-non-technology type stuff
like free speech and lack of censorship
right i i couldn't even believe in more
and you know i was a uh uh soldier in
the united states army i went to iraq
right and so i have a very specific kind
of experience in life that most people
don't have
um but in recent light of um
a lot of the social unrest in the united
states one of the things that uh has
absolutely blown my mind
is we're a country that hangs its hat on
free speech
but it seems every day like we're moving
more towards a world where
it's encouragement of free speech if you
say the things i agree with
which cancer is that's your big problem
that's not free speech
right and so i you know i've aired my
grievances about this all over the place
and basically said
you know the the testing of free speech
happens most
when somebody is saying something you
disagree with so
it was important for me to have this
conversation mainly because i thought a
lot of people
thought that we shouldn't have the
conversation right and so that was kind
of one one key piece
the other thing is i've made you know
we've invested over 100 million dollars
in
early stage companies over the last four
years um back to all kinds of companies
both in uh kind of the crypto space and
a bunch of
uh more that are not in the crypto space
and the one thing that
uh i think when i look at objectively i
say
i understand both arguments i personally
believe and have a very deep conviction
in um the idea that the market adoption
ends up buying time for the technology
to be built versus
uh technology leading to the market
adoption leading to the winning right
and so is there a possibility that
that's the wrong assessment of course
the right
you're always possible to be wrong um
but
the way that i invest right is
i basically make an analysis and i'm
willing to be very binary in nature
right so i'm willing to um kind of make
an assessment
and it's this belief that like the
concentration is actually a better
strategy for me personally
than diversification right so it's kind
of like the warranty we're getting
ethereum or any other coins or only
bitcoin i know nothing
else yeah and so again very rare i think
in a lot of cases like there's plenty of
people who kind of own all this other
stuff
um but but it's not a bitcoin versus
bitcoin cash thing it's literally just
a bitcoin versus everything else thing
of like hey i've got very deep seated
conviction here and and this is
where where i think um i want to spend
my time uh
and i think the other piece of this and
you
hinted at this earlier and probably one
of the number one
questions that i get from uh
institutional investors
is um ultimately the competition the
real battle
right as i say that the crypto world is
going to put forth
something to be the global reserve
currency right now the market's
determined that that thing is bitcoin
um and it's going to have to compete on
a monetary policy level with fiat
currencies
whatever the thing ends up being put
forward like that's going to be the
really big battle
and so it's funny to me that there's so
much divisiveness and fighting and all
this kind of stuff in the crypto world
because i think people forget that the
battle between
a deflationary asset and an inflationary
asset like
that's a that's a big deal right like
that that's the walk in the park and so
um i think that that coming at some
point i don't know if that's
two years away 10 years away 20 years
away you know whatever it is
but but i think that that's the other
thing i always kind of keep my eye
on the prize a little bit of like
ultimately that's going to be the thing
that determines way more than
pretty much any other debate that goes
on in in kind of the crypto industry if
you will
yeah that would be my biggest sadness if
if what winds up playing out here is
that
rather than the entire world winding up
using a hard money asset with a limited
supply
uh they all just wind up using you know
digital dollars on the blockchain and
the federal reserve can print more
digital dollars anytime they want and
it seems like it could possibly head in
that direction to me and that that would
be really sad
i will have a slightly better improved
version of the dollar but
uh nowhere near as good of a version of
money for the world that we could have
had if we had uh
played our cards a bit better absolutely
um
listen thank you so much for doing this
i i think that
hopefully you got some value out of this
and i can already see from people's
responses that
uh they got a ton of value out of just
understanding not only one the work you
did on the early days of bitcoin but
kind of how you see the world today
uh obviously i think we've got you know
some diversions of opinion but but
i'm happy that you and i can have kind
of a very rational conversation just
about
what is happening right now um and so
hopefully as
as this continues we'll be able to do it
again in the future but thank you
if you like pomp's content and his
channel subscribe share the video on
social media tell a friend
set them up with any cryptocurrency
wallet you want send them a little bit
show them how it works
roger all right we're just going to
spread the whole world as fast as we can
it doesn't matter which cryptocurrency
it is use the one you like the most and
uh
go out and uh tell a friend now roger's
gonna get
accused of being a pomp shill on twitter
it's uh
you're not gonna be able to win man up
in the prompt so go out and spread this
message here because we want as many
people to be aware of the infrastructure
and ecosystem as we possibly can and
pump is one of the the best messengers
the space has out there we're not like
i've listened to lots of your interviews
and like
when you talk about the problems i'm not
in my head the whole time and it's just
like
what's the solution to get to the world
that we want to be in we have slightly
different strategies but
the end target seems to be almost
identical there so
awesome thank you so much for doing this
thank you too see you next time